STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS -- MISTER
FRASIER'S HERE ALREADY SO WE'LL
ASK HIM TO COME UP.
IT BY PARDON ME IF I. S. STOP
YOUR PRESENTATION IF WE ALL OF A
SUDDEN GET A QUORUM.
AND THAT WE WE CAN TAKE ACTION
ON ON THE ITEM WELCOME THE
MORNING THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS.
AB TWO EIGHTY FOUR IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT WILL ENHANCE YOUTH
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS.
BY DELETING THE SUNSET ON THE
JUNIOR HUNTING LICENCES AGE
EXTENSION ADOPTED IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN WHICH MADE
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
YOUTH -- ELIGIBLE FOR A REDUCE
COSTS JUNIOR HUNTING LICENSE.
CALIFORNIA LIKE OTHER STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY FACES A
DECLINE IN HUNTING PARTICIPATION.
ACCESS TO REDUCE COSTS YOUR
HUNTER LICENSES WAS IDENTIFIED
BY THE OUTDOORS COMMUNITY AS ONE
STRATEGY TO GET MORE YOUTH
INVOLVED.
IN CONSERVATION AND HUNTING
ACTIVITIES.
SAYS THE LICENSE WAS INTRODUCED
YOUTH HUNTERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
INCREASED IN NUMBER.
IN FACT THE JUNIOR HUNTING
LICENSE BROUGHT IN MORE YOUTH
HUNTERS IN ANY YEAR SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX A THIRTY
YEAR HIGH.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE JUNIOR
HUNTERS.
THE JUNIOR HUNTERS -- IT BROUGHT
IN WERE PREVIOUSLY EXCLUDED DUE
TO COST.
THE YOUTH LICENSE EXPOSE THESE
KIDS TO OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE MISSED OUT ON
OTHERWISE.
THE JUNIOR HIGH THE JUNIOR
LICENSE HAS HAD AN UNMISTAKABLY
POSITIVE IMPACT.
WHICH CAN BE SEEN IN THE NUMBERS
AND FROM THE TESTIMONY YOU WILL
HEAR TODAY.
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE SOLUTION
THAT IMPROVES AND PROMOTES
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS FOR OUR
YOUTH.
AND NOW I'VE PRESENT WITH OF ARE
SUPPORTED SO MARKEDLY FROM
CALIFORNIA WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SOME IN FRAZIER YEAH
MARKEDLY CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION WE WORKED A WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER ON THE
ORIGINAL BILL -- OTHERS POINT
OUT THAT YOU KNOW FOLLOW
FOLLOWING CALIFORNIA'S WE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE US
FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE ALSO
CHANGE ITS FEDERAL.
YOUTH HONEY AN AGE REQUIREMENT
FROM.
FIFTEEN TO SEVENTEEN SO THAT HAS
BEEN ADOPTED -- MANY OTHER
STATES ALSO ALLOW. SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS. TO PURCHASE
A REDUCED FEE -- HUNTING
LICENCES.
THIS INCLUDES NEIGHBORING OREGON
AND ARIZONA.
AND EVEN -- OTHER STATES
THROUGHOUT THE WEST I KNOW MANY
OF THEM ALSO HAVE THESE LICENSES.
THE MAIN BENEFIT FOR THE JUNIOR
LICENSE HOLDER IS REALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
SPECIAL MENTORED YOUTH HEIGHTS --
THAT HELPED INTRODUCE THEM TO
THE OUTDOORS.
THIS HELPS TO ADDRESS -- THE
SURVEY DATA FROM HUNTERS THAT
SUGGESTS THAT.
ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY AND
PARTICULARLY GETTING PEOPLE OUT --
WHO ARE ADULTS THAT HELPED TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO THE OUTDOORS
AFFECTS HUNTING PARTICIPATION SO
WE'RE TRYING TO GO OFF OF THE
DATA THAT -- IS ALREADY OUT
THERE -- BUT ALSO THE REDUCED
FEE -- COSTS THE JUNIOR LICENSE
OBVIOUSLY IT'LL HELP YOUTH
HUNTERS BECAUSE THEIR TYPICALLY
AT AN AGE WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE
AN INCOME AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO SPEND A LOT ON THEIR HUNTING
ACTIVITIES.
SO WORTH IT WE THINK WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT PATH AND OF COURSE WE
HAVE THE WHOLE ARE THREE EFFORT
GOING ON WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM AS WELL.
AND WE THINK THIS IS JUST ONE
TOOL BUT A VERY IMPORTANT TOOL
TO HELP.
HOPEFULLY -- INCREASE HUNTER
PARTICIPATION OVER LONG TERM OR
LONG TERM -- SO WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER FOR HIS WORK
ON THIS AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OTHER.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MARK
SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE GRASSLAND
WATER DISTRICT IN THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GUIDES AND
SPORTSMEN'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BILL GAINES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION NATIONAL WILD TURKEY
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA HAWKING
CLUB TELERI BASIN WETLANDS
ASSOCIATION THE SYSOON RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT AND THE
BLACK.
GROUP AND SUPPORT THANK
[inaudible]
ANY OTHER [inaudible] ONE TWENTY
FOUR IN OPPOSITION.
THAT THAT IS THE QUESTION.
MEMBERS OF GREAT.
I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND ASK IF HE WAS TAKING ANY A
CO AUTHORS.
YES SIR WOULD BE HONORED TO HAVE
YOU AS CLUB.
THAT WOULD BE.
GREAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
OUR QUESTIONS.
THE BILL.
MOTION.
WE HAVE A CORD. FOR WORKING ON
THE FACT [inaudible] FOR THE
THANK YOU MISTER PRITCHARD TIME
[inaudible]
FOLLOWED BY.
MORNING WHAT GOOD MORNING.
YOU HAVE TO PASS -- COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT RECOMMENDATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- CAN I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR WORK IN ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS -- AS WE ALL KNOW
SITTING IN HERE.
SOME OF THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES
OF CALIFORNIA WATER MANAGEMENT
CAN BE FOUND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING NOT
CONTAMINATE DRINKING WATER OR
OVERDRAFT GROUND WATER BASINS
THE SILICON VALLEY NEED THE
ABILITY TO USE EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX.
AVAILABLE IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
OUR GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
GOALS.
A RECENT PPA SEE STUDY FOCUSED
ON THE FUTURE OF WATER
MANAGEMENT IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
AND THEY NOTE THAT THE ONLY
FEASIBLE WAY TO BRING OUR GROUND
WATER BASINS BACK INTO BALANCE
IS TO A COMBINED APPROACH.
OF AUGMENTING SUPPLY IN REDUCING
DEMAND.
THE STORY OF OUR LIVES.
WHAT A BEFORE FOUR ONE ATTEMPTS
TO DO IS BRING THE CONVERSATION
TO THE FOREFRONT BY SUGGESTING
THAT ONE POSSIBLE SOLUTION?
THAT CAN PROVIDE MULTIPLE
BENEFITS IS GROUND WATER
RECHARGE.
WE KNOW THIS IS A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION WE ALL KNOW WHAT
BEEN HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
FOR YEARS NOW -- BUT AS THE
SIGMA DEADLINES COME UP UPON US
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE TOOK A PASS ON
IT BECAUSE IT WOULD IF IT IS A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION.
BUT AS FOR YEARS HAVE NOW PASSED
AND I THINK WE'RE BACK TO HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION AND NEED TO
FIND WAYS TO MOVE FORWARD --
WITH ME HERE TODAY -- IS MARIANN
ORNAMENT FROM RC RC AND DANNY
MERKLEY OF THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU TO TALK MORE ABOUT THIS
AND WITH OUR HOPES THAT WE
CONTINUE. TO CREATED OPEN AND
HONEST DIALOGUE ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES AND COMPLEXITIES
FACING EACH OF OUR REGION'S
UNIQUE WATER ISSUES THANK.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MARYANN WARMER I'M WITH THAT
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THIRTY
SIX OF THE STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
WE APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
POLICY QUESTION AND SHE NOTED
THIS CAN BE AND HAS PROVEN TO BE
A VERY DIFFICULT C<c.cyan></c>
CONVERSATION.
WITH IMPLICATIONS TO WATER RIGHT
HOLDERS AS WELL AS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO ACHIEVE
SUCCESS THROUGH THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACTED
WITH ADOPTED BY.
US THE PEOPLE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AS ALREADY NOTED SEVERAL RECENT
STUDIES HAVE POINTED OUT THE
CHALLENGES FACING THESE EFFORTS
AND THE RISK OF FAILURE CAN MEAN
THE FOUNDING OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ACRES.
IT IS OUR VIEW THAT DESIGNATING
GROUNDWATER RECHARGES THE
BENEFICIAL USE IS A KEY TOOL TO
BRING RK GROUND WATER BASINS
INTO COMPLIANCE.
BALANCE AND PROTECTING THE
RESOURCE FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THE CHALLENGE WILL BE FINDING
THE RIGHT MECHANISM THAT IS
PROTECTIVE OF WATER RIGHT
HOLDERS AS WELL AS THE
DOWNSTREAM USERS.
THE PASSAGE OF SIGMA HAS CREATED
THE FRAMEWORK FOR COUNTIES WATER
AGENCIES AND THE COMMUNITY OF
STAKEHOLDERS. TO COLLABORATE ON
IN THE CREATION OF A GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN.
WHICH BEST MEETS THE NEEDS OF
THE COMMUNITIES THE ECONOMIES
THAT DEPEND UPON THAT WATER.
AND THE STEWARDSHIP OF
CALIFORNIA'S OUT AQUIFER'S.
CIGNA ALSO PROVIDES A FORM TO DO
SO THAT AS TRANSPARENT.
AND PROVIDES THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOCALLY DRIVEN
SUCCESS.
STATED ANOTHER WAY GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES HAVE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR ENSURING
THAT SIGMA IS PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTED.
AND SHOULD PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN ANY FRAMEWORK FOR
IMPLEMENTING RECHARGE AS A
BENEFICIAL USE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
EGGMAN LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
ADVANCE THIS POLICY QUESTION FOR
THE GOOD OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE AQUIFER'S WE
DEPEND UPON THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS --
AND GAINING BERKELEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU -- LET ME
BEGIN BY SAYING THAT -- FORM
YOU'RE REALLY APPRECIATES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADMINS WILLING
TO TAKE ON THIS -- TOUGH ISSUE
IN IN RECENT YEARS.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF THE SUSPEND
WILL GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
FARM BUREAU AND COUNTY FARM
BUREAU'S HAD SPENT THOUSANDS OF
HOURS -- AND ATTENDED HUNDREDS
OF MEETINGS TO MAKE SURE THE ACT
IS SUCCESSFUL. FOR THIS REASON
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF DOES ANY
GROUND WATER RECHARGE AS A
BENEFICIAL USED AS ONE KEY TOOL --
TO BRING YOUR GROUND WATER
BASINS IN THE BALANCE WHILE
PROTECTING.
MORE JUNIOR WATER RIGHT HOLDERS
AND DOWNSTREAM WATER USERS.
WE STILL HAVE.
WORK TO DO IN PROVIDING THE
FRAMEWORK NECESSARY -- TO
BENEFICIALLY UC'S EXCESS FLOWS
WHEN THEY ARE AVAILABLE -- TO
RECHARGE OUR BASINS AND OFFERING
PROTECTIONS FOR FOR ALL WATER
USERS.
WERE HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- SO THAT A. B..
FOUR FOUR ONE CAN PROVIDE
MULTIPLE.
BENEFITS BOOK GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE AS WELL AS FLOOD
PROTECTION.
IN WET YEARS LIKE THIS -- WHEN
WATER IS COMING OFF THE
LANDSCAPE -- IN SHEETS AND
FLOWING OUT THROUGH OUR FLOOD
CONTROL SYSTEMS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
INCUMBENT UPON US -- TO
RECAPTURE IT FOR RECHARGE. TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN CAPTURE
WATER.
IT IS GOING TO HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS MOVE FORWARD IN
TERMS OF WATER SUPPLY AND IT IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TOOL.
OF FOR IMPLEMENTING SIGMA.
AB FOUR FOUR ONE WILL ALSO HELP
BUREAU OF RECLAMATION TO RELEASE
WATER FOR GROUND WATER RECHARGE
TO THOSE THAT HAVE STORED.
AND PAID FOR WATER RIGHT NOW.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE DRIVE
VOTE TO KEEP THIS MEASURE AND
THE DIALOGUE MOVING FORWARD -- I
REALLY HIT THIS A VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE WITH A PRETTY BROAD BRUSH
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS --
THANK YOU OF OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO WANTED TO SPEAK WITH HIM FOR
HI DOMINIC TOMARI FOR THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER EXCHANGE
CONTRACTORS WATER AUTHORITY.
WE JUST GOT IN A POSITION ON
THIS ON FRIDAY IT'S A POSITION
OF SUPPORT AND THEY'LL BE LETTER
TO FOLLOW BUT I JUST WANT TO DO --
ISSUE OR SUPPORT POSITION HERE
TODAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHAT ELSE?
I THOSE ARE ONES BEACON
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE -- COMPORT
.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M KATHY VIçT TELE
THE EXECUTIVE LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND REGRETTABLY METROPOLITAN
ANOTHER AGENCIES AS NOTED HONDA
LETTER SUBMITTED TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE MUST OPPOSE A
BEFORE FOUR ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SUSAN EGGMAN.
AB FOUR FOUR ONE FAILS TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT SAFEGUARDS TO
ENSURE THAT PERMANENT
UNDERGROUND STORAGE IS
IMPLEMENTED IN A REASONABLE
MANNER.
IN MANY AREAS OF THE STATE THERE
MAY BE SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS TO
RECOVERING GROUNDWATER LEVELS
AND LEAVING WATER IN THE GROUND.
AND THE GROUND AQUIFER
PERMANENTLY HOWEVER THE WATER
RIGHTS OF THOSE POTENTIALLY
AFFECTED BY SUCH ACTIONS.
MUST BE RECOGNIZED AND PROTECTED.
THIS IS DANIEL GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN RECOGNIZE THE
INTERRELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
SURFACE WATER AND GROUNDWATER
AND PROTECTION OF EXISTING WATER
RIGHTS.
AND A BEFORE FORTY ONE SHOULD DO
SO AS WELL.
THERE'S ALSO THE POTENTIAL FOR
SUBSTANTIAL MISUSE AN ADVERSE
IMPACTS OF SURFACE WATER IS
PERMANENTLY STORED WITHOUT
APPROPRIATE REVIEW AND APPROVAL
BY THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
PARTIES SHOULD HAVE TO ESTABLISH
WITH THE BOARD THAT PERMANENT
UNDERGROUND WATER STORAGE IS
NECESSARY TO AVOID SALT WATER
INTRUSION OR SUBSIDENCE OR
ANOTHER IMPORTANT BENEFICIAL
EFFECT. TO ENSURE OUR STATE'S
AQUIFER'S CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY WATER SUPPLIES.
UNCHECKED THE DIVERSION OF WATER
FOR UNDER BROWN STORAGE WHETHER
A NEW OR EXISTING APPROPRIATION
MAY ADVERSELY IMPACT OTHER
BENEFICIAL USES OF WATER FOR
FISH AND WILDLIFE RECREATION
COMMERCE OR USE BY A DOWNSTREAM
DIVERT HER.
AND APPROVING THE APPROPRIATION
OF SURFACE WATER FOR PERMANENT
STORAGE THE STATE WATER BOARD
MUST CONFIRM THAT THE FLOWS ARE
NOT ALREADY OTHERWISE
APPROPRIATED OR DIVERTED AT
TIMES WHEN THE FEDERAL CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT.
AND STATE WATER PROJECT ARE
REQUIRED TO RELEASE SUPPLEMENTAL
PROJECT WATER TO MEET WATER
QUALITY OBJECTIVES IN THE DELTA
WATERSHED.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE
AB FOR ONE AND URGE THE
COMMITTEES NO VOTE ON THE
MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AT MANNING
ON BEHALF OF MY HOBBY WATER
AGENCY IN WATSON'S WATER
DISTRICT -- THIS IS ABOUT THE
FOURTH TIME I THINK A TESTIFIED
ON THIS BILL.
IN THIS FORM -- AND A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WE WORKED WITH MISS
SEGMENT INNER STAFF TO REACH A
RESOLUTION AND UNFORTUNATELY --
THE BILL DIDN'T PROCEED AT THAT
POINT -- LAST YEAR A NUMBER OF A
SPENT EXTENSIVE TIME MOST OF THE
YOU'RE WORKING ON MISTER RANDALL
IS BILL WHICH THE CHAIRS
CARRYING IN A DIFFERENT FORM
TODAY.
WORKING WITH VERY STAKEHOLDERS
AND THE WATER BOARD ON COMPLEX
WATER RIGHTS ISSUES --
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL IN THIS
FORM DOESN'T IN CAPS LATE.
BAIT FOR MAJOR THEMES THAT ARE
ANY BILL IN THIS AREA REALLY
NEEDS TO ENCOMPASS -- FIRST IS
THAT THE BILL SHOULD BE
RESTRICTED TO TIMES WHEN THEY'RE
FLOOD FLOWS.
MEANING THERE'S ACCESS WATER IN
THE SYSTEM -- THAT IS
RECOGNIZABLE TO EVERYONE --
SECOND THE LANGUAGE US HAVE
ADEQUATE -- PROTECTIONS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL WATER MEANING FOR
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THIRD THE LANGUAGE HAS TO
PROTECT WATER QUALITY OF
PROTECTIONS -- SO WHETHER IT BE
SAILING LEVELS OR WHATEVER THEIR
NUMERICAL STANDARDS THAT HAVE TO
BE MET.
AND FOURTH A AND AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IT HAS TO PROTECT
OTHER WATER RIGHT USERS.
AS AN EXAMPLE -- SOMEONE IN THE
DELTA COULD DIVERT WATER UNDER
THIS BILL IS WRITTEN.
ESTABLISH A OF OUR WATER RIGHTS
SIMPLY BY TAKING WATER -- THAT
SHOULD BE IN THE SYSTEM FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT RELEASED BY THE
STATE OR FEDERAL CONTRACTORS.
TAKING THAT WATER OUT OF THE
SYSTEM AND PUTTING IN IN THE
GROUND.
THAT LEADS TO THE EXPORT
COMMUNITY HOW MANY PUT
ADDITIONAL WATER AND FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
WHILE SOMEONE ELSE IS TAKEN
WATER OUT.
AND NOW SALAS FOR WATER RIGHT
THAT'S NOT A PALATABLE SITUATION.
ON WE'D SUGGESTS THAT -- YOU
KNOW FOR A BILL TO MOVE FORWARD.
IT IT REALLY CAN ENCOMPASS THOSE
PRINCIPLES AND STILL PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENHANCE
GROUNDWATER STORAGE FOR THOSE
REASONS WE OPPOSE TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OTHERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALSO KNOWN
AS SALLY WATER AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRYSTIE FOR A WITH
THE THREE VALLEY'S MISCIBLE
WATER DISTRICT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY NWT THANK YOU.
GINGER MEMBERS JACK WHILE GOING
UP IT ALSO IN OPPOSITION ON
BEHALF OF KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY LONG BEACH WATER
DEPARTMENT AND THE SAN BURDEN
YOUR VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TERRY MEMBERS
PUBLIC OURS WITH ENVIRONMENT
DEFENSE FUND I'M GOING LAST
BECAUSE I WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL RIGHT NOW.
I PROBABLY SHOULD TRY TO SPEAKER
THERE BUT HERE I AM -- I THINK
WE'VE HAD THE PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHERS OFFICE
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE GOAL
OF THE BILL.
AND THE PRIOR BILLS AS WELL I
THINK WE'RE FULLY ON BOARD WITH
THEM.
XCELERATED GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
PROJECTS AROUND THE STATE I
THINK WE THIS IS A SIMILAR
BUILDING WITH.
YOU AS OTHERS HAVE SAID HAD
DEALT WITH THIS ISSUE THE PAST
FEW YEARS.
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT TWEAKING
OR CHANGING BENEFITS ARE USED AS
ATTENTION.
SPECIFICALLY REMOVING THE
FORFEITURE PROVISIONS TO WATER
RIGHTS SO WHEN WATER IS NOT.
USE FOR GREAT IN FIVE YEARS.
UNDER THIS BILL UNDER THE
CURRENT FORM THE BILL WOULD NOT
BE FORFEITED.
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
IN THE UNDERSTAND THAT WE WANT
TO PUT WATER IN THE GROUND FIRST
USE OF STOP SEE WATER INTRUSION
FOR OTHER REASONS.
YOU THINK THAT COULD BE THE
PERSON SENATE SO WE WANT TO KEEP
WORKING ON THIS AND TRY TO
FIGURE THIS OUT THERE'S OTHER
YOU THERE'S OTHER EFFORTS AT THE
WATER BOARD AND AT THE PART AND
WATER RESOURCES AND SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
RECOGNITION OF THE NEED. TO TO
DO THIS -- SO WE'LL KEEP TALKING
IN A PUT SOME THOUGHTS DOWN IN
WRITING.
RELATED EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU UP WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE POINTS WERE MADE
WELL I I THINK SOME OF THE
POINTS MADE ARE ARE.
ARE SALIENT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT MISTER MANNING YOU KNOW
POINTING TO THE TENACITY OF THE
EFFORT BEHIND THIS BILL -- IT IS
NOT EASY YOU KNOW WATER WATER IS
NEVER EASY BUT WE KNOW THAT IF
WE KEEP ON DRAINING AQUIFER'S
AND KEEP ON TAKING IT OUT
WITHOUT HAVING A PLAN TO
RECHARGE THEM -- THAT'S NOT
HEALTHY AND WE WE CERTAINLY
INVITE AND THAT'S THE GET THE
POINT OF THE BILL TO BRING
PEOPLE BACK TO THE TABLE TO
SOMETHING.
AT I THINK EVERYBODY AGREES IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE IT IS VERY HARD
TO THREAD THE NEEDLE ON THIS BUT
WE ARE COMMITTED. TO DOING THAT.
AND MAKING SURE THAT JUNIOR
WATER RIGHTS AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO TAKE FROM PEOPLE
BUT WE KNOW THAT IS IMPORTANT
YOU CAN'T AGAIN JUST DID THE
IMAGE OF A STRIKE JUST CAN'T
KEEP TAKING IT OUT.
WITHOUT PUTTING WATER BACK IN
AND THINK WE'RE GOING TO
MAINTAIN A HEALTHY SYSTEM WHICH
WAS THE THE WHOLE POINT OF OF
SIGMA AND KNOWING THAT WE NEED --
TO HAVE A SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN.
SO WE WERE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH YOU ON THE BILL AND AS WAS
MENTIONED THERE'S ANOTHER
VEHICLE AS WELL THAT WE CORRECT
UP TO INTEGRATE YOU INTO THAT
CONVERSATION WE HAVE A QUORUM
KNOWN SO I'M GONNA CALL THE ROLL.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE
ACTION ON YOUR BILL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EDUARDO GARCIA HASN'T
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible] TO DALLY.
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA YEAH
[inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
WOOD.
OKAY WE'LL FOR WE HAVE QUESTION
FOR A MISSPELLING SO -- I NEVER
KNOWN YOU TO SHY OFF OF THE
TOUGH.
BILL AND THIS IS REALLY A TOUGH
BILL THERE ARE A LOT OF FIRST I
COMMEND YOU FOR EVEN.
TRYING THIS OUT AGAIN -- IN MY
DISTRICT WE ARE FACED WITH --
THIS IS SEGMENT IT'S NOT REALLY
WORKING WITH THEM IN DIFFERENT
PARTS I GUESS WHAT MY QUESTION
IS YOU KNOW DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE RECHARGE DIFFERENTLY
AND SO WE HAVE -- THEY'RE KINDA
GROUNDWATER BASINS AND DOLLIES
AND ENDEAVOR TO TOUCH OUR SOULS
WERE YOU CAN AND CAN'T RECHARGE
SENIOR WATER RIGHTS AND
CONJUNCTIVE USE I MEAN I'M NOT
TELLING YOU ANYTHING YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND ALREADY I KNOW BUT
WHAT.
WHAT IS THIS BILL GOING TO GO TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE?
AT THAT BUT I FIRST WANTED LIKE
TO APPROPRIATIONS OKAY SO THIS
IS REALLY ARE SHOT AT WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANY.
REAL DIALOGUE ON THE POLICY THEN
[inaudible]
SO -- FOR ME I THINK THAT -- I'M
A REALLY.
KIND OF DON'T KNOW WHERE I'M A
LAND ON THIS BILL I I HAVEN'T OF
STAIN ON IT BECAUSE IT'S THERE'S
JUST SO MANY UNANSWERED.
QUESTIONS AND I KNOW THAT THIS
HAS BEEN TRIED MANY TIMES SO I
GUESS -- WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON --
MAYBE.
DIVIDE UP THE STATE AND MAYBE
SOME REGIONS AND MAYBE SEE IN
SOME BECAUSE IT YOU MOST YOUR
OPPOSITION IS COMING FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND THERE ARE DIFFERENCES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT I I
AGREE THAT WE NEED -- TO THEY
WERE AREAS WE CAN RECHARGE WE
NEED TO RECHARGE AS BASES IN THE
VALLEY -- YOU KNOW PORTABILITY
IN THE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN.
WHICH IS YOUR AREA ISN'T IT.
RIGHT PACKED YOUR ARE YOU MORE
OF YOUR DISTRICT ARE DIFFERENT
RESIDENTS SO.
I'M I'M JUST KIND OF WONDER IS
THERE IS THERE AN OPPORTUNITY
MAYBE TO LOOK AT THE STATE AND
REGIONS OF HANDLING THE RECHARGE
IN THE THOSE THINGS.
IN DIFFERENT WAY.
FOR DIFFERENT REGIONS THE STATE.
I'LL TAKE A STAB AT ANSWERING
THAT MISTER DALI MERION WARMER
DOWN WITH RC RC.
WE THINK THAT THERE IS SOME
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THOSE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IN THEIR
REPORT RISK REPORTING
RESPONSIBILITIES -- ARE IMMINENT --
AT THE END OF JANUARY OF NEXT
YEAR.
SO WE THINK THAT WILL ALSO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE.
WE THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
VEHICLE AT LEAST TO GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY START SCOPING OUT.
ON GIVEN THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
SUCCESSFUL YET TO CONTINUE TO
TRY TO START SCOPING OUT WHAT
MIGHT BE IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF LOCALLY DRIVEN SIGMA.
PROGRAMS TO HELP US.
MAINTAIN THE AQUIFER'S INTO THE
FUTURE RIGHT NOW PARTICULARLY IN
THE SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
WE HAVE SOME REAL CHALLENGES AND
WE JUST BE THIS IS ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX.
SO I GUESS THE ANSWER IS IN SOME
WAYS YES I THINK ONE ONE PEOPLE
CRAFT THEIR PLANS THEN IF THEY
HAD THIS IS A TOOL AND MET
CERTAIN CRITERIA.
THEN I THINK WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED SO I THINK THOSE ARE
ALL CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE VERY
OPEN TO HAVING. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE FACED WITH IS
THE AVAILABILITY OF FUNDING TO
ACTUALLY EVEN IMPLEMENT THE
SIGNAL PLAN AND MOST OF MOST OF
THE GROUND WATER USERS MY
DISTRICT ARE AG AND THEN SMALL
WATER DISTRICTS.
THAT TERM ARE STRAPPED FOR
FUNDING TO START OUT WITH SO
THAT THE SIGNAL REGULATION IS.
IMPAIR DAM FOR MAIL TO YOU YOU
HAVE PROP TWO EIGHTEEN WHERE YOU
CAN'T REYES CAN'T RAISE REVENUES
AND QUITE FRANKLY SOME OF THOSE
CAN.
WATER SYSTEMS CAN'T CAN'T AFFORD
IT.
AND SO WE'RE STOCK IT WERE IN A
BOX WE WE HAVE.
A GREAT AND IN THAT SUPPOSEDLY
AN IMPACT IMPAIR GROUNDWATER
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO PROVE THE
MONITORING WHICH IS AN HASN'T
BEEN DONE FOR EVER.
AND SO IT WE'RE KIND OF IN A BOX
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO GET US OUT OF THAT BOX AND
MOVE FORWARD I OBVIOUSLY WE
DON'T WANT.
TO OVER DROPPED OUR GROUNDWATER --
IN.
AND WE WANT TO RECHARGE WHERE WE
CAN IN SOME OF THOSE AREAS THREE
CHARGES ARE DIFFERENT THAN
OTHERS AND SO ANYWAY I'M CUTS
IT'S DIFFICULT YES YES.
HERE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- EGGMAN
I REALLY APPRECIATE -- YOU BRING
THE BILL FORD BUT AS YOU KNOW
WERE FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND OUR ISSUES ARE.
OF VERY COMPLEX AS WELL AND I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE FOR IT
FOR YOUR DISTRICT AND I AM ALSO
WOULD LIKE -- AND I'M HEARING IT
HERE YOUR COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING IT'S OBVIOUSLY -- A NOR
THAN CALIFORNIA VERSUS SENDING
CALIFORNIA ISSUE I DON'T I HOPE
IT WOULD.
BE DIFFERENT I'M BY THE A LOT OF
MY FOLKS DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SOME OF A MERRY HERE --
HAVE ISSUES WITH THE BILL SO AT
THIS TIME I WILL -- SUPPORTED --
GIVEN THAT YOU'VE GIVEN THE
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE -- LIKE -- THE
OLDEN DAYS OF WATERS FOR YOUR
FIGHTING WITH USE FOR DRINKING
THE OTHER WAY AROUND BUT I DON'T
WANT THIS TO BECOME A A HUGE
FIGHT I THINK THAT THERE'S SOME --
SOLUTIONS THAT WE CAN ALL LIVE
WITH AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS. TO TO WORK WITH US
THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD JUST -- I'LL JUST
REITERATE THAT IS ANYBODY KNOWS
BEEN AROUND HERE FOR AWHILE THAT
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
AWHILE AND WE CAN'T GET TO SOME
KIND OF AGREEMENT WE WE DON'T WE
DON'T WE DON'T TRY TO FORCE
ISSUE AND PUSH IT FORWARD.
YOU KNOW I DON'T SEE IT AS A
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I SEE IT AS A
CALIFORNIA ISSUE AND IT'S WATER
ISSUE AND IT'S ALL OF OUR ISSUE --
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE THE
RICHEST FARMLAND IN THE WORLD
THAT IS THEN WITH BROWN THAT
WATER THAT IS OVER DRAFTED WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE CLEAN DRINKING
WATER.
AND THIS IS JUST PART OF THE
CONVERSATION THE PERSON WITH THE
BIGGEST YOU KNOW.
STRAW SHOULDN'T GET THE CHEN
ALWAYS BE ABLE TO GET THE MOST
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE THE GROUND IS HEALTHY
THAT THE AQUIFER IS OUR FULL.
IN UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES
OF DIFFERENT BASINS HAVING
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
THAT.
I JUST WANTED -- TO DANNY
MERKLEY WITH CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT --
IF.
FARM BUREAU SAW THIS IS A NORTH
SOUTH ISSUE I WOULDN'T BE
SITTING HERE -- LARGEST SAG
ORGANIZATIONS CITY CALIFORNIA
WITH MEMBERS -- FROM THE OREGON
BORDER DOWN TO THE MEXICAN
BORDER.
AND THAT'S WHY -- WERE WORKING
WITH -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROTECTIONS FOR JUNIOR WATER
RIGHT HOLDERS IN DOWNSTREAM
WATER USERS ARE THERE IN THIS
MEASURE.
AND IF I MIGHT ADD LIKEWISE TO
THE FARM BUREAU WE'RE NOT A
REGIONAL REGIONAL ORGANIZATION
WE HAVE MEMBER COUNTIES FROM.
THE MEXICAN BORDER TO THE OREGON
BORDER AS WELL WHAT I WOULD
POINT OUT IS THAT WE DO THIS
MORE AS AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR US
TO ROUTE RESTORE AQUIFER'S AND
MAINTAINING THOSE AQUIFER'S IS
GOOD FOR ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WHEREVER WERE LOCATED WE HAVE A
PRETTY INTEGRATED WATER.
INTO INFRASTRUCTURE -- IT THESE
DAYS AND WE WOULD LOOK THIS LOOK
AT THIS AS A WAY FOR COMMUNITIES
THROUGH CIGNA. TO MANAGE THEIR
BASINS IN A WAY THAT'S NOT ONLY
GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY CENTER
DEPENDENT UPON THEM BUT BIRD THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DEPENDENT
UPON THEM AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COME IN HERE PLEASE
STOP.
THANK CHAIR I ALSO WHILE -- I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ARE.
THE OBJECTIONS ARE RAISED A BY
THE ALMOST TWO DAYS OF IN
CALIFORNIA WATER -- DISHING
METROPOLITAN NOW -- WATER WAS OF
IN CALIFORNIA SLANG CALIFORNIA
WATER DISTRICT -- WHAT WATER
COALITION OUR WAY GOING TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THE CONCERNS AND --
IN THAT YOU HAVE HEARD DOWN FROM
THOSE GREW UP OPPOSITION GROUP.
THEY ARE CERTAINLY NOT
OBJECTIONS THAT WE HAVEN'T HEARD
BEFORE AND WE HAVE MOVED THE
BILL ALONG TO THE POINT WHERE IN
IN THE PAST.
MOST OF YOU THE PERSON PEOPLE
YOU HEARD OBJECTING HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO COME TO A COMFORTABLE
PLACE BUT THEN.
WHEN WE GET TO TOO COMFORTABLE
WITH SOME WE WE LOSE?
OF OUR OF OUR FRIENDS SO IT IS A
I AM COMMITTED TO TRYINGTO WORK
THIS OUT IS A IT IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE -- BUT PEOPLE COMING TO
THE TABLE AND DISCUSSING IT AND
EVERYBODY BUT I THINK BEING
CONCERNED ABOUT.
WATER CALIFORNIA WILL GET THEIR
THE ONE THE ONE THING I MIGHT
ADD TO THAT IS -- NOW MR
GARCIA'S MEASURE THAT TALKS TO
THE PROCESS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FORMALIZE -- FOR THIS KIND OF
ACTIVITY WE THINK IT'S ALL
COMPLIMENTARY AND THAT AS WE
TALK THIS THROUGH. TO GATHER
THERE WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BRING THIS ISSUE TO THE NEXT
GENERATION OF OF IMPLEMENTATION.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU HELLO WITH A
LONGER FORM.
SO WE WILL TAKE ACTION PLAN.
OKAY.
WILL TAKE IS OUR MOTION.
THE MOTION IS OUR SECOND.
I'LL SECOND IT -- ENCLOSING.
JUST THAT THANK YOU OFFER FOR
BEING OPEN THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU TO THE SUPPORTERS AS
WELL AS THE OPPOSITION I LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATION GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU ALL AS A CONTRACTOR
KALRA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HI GARCIA AYE GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI NO CHIU.
CHIU I VALLEY.
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE [inaudible]
BLANCA RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS WOOD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST NIGHT OF THE WEEK.
EIGHTY FOUR LARA.
SEC THAT WILL.
BE TO THE FORM OF THE SECOND
LINE [inaudible]
YEAH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHIU I DALLY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I'D GLORIA
[inaudible]
KALRA.
LEVINE.
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOULD.
THANK YOU READY TO TAKE UP ITEM.
SEVEN IT IS.
EIGHT YOU SHOULD DO THAT YES
[inaudible]
SECOND [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB THREE THREE SIX MATHIS AB
FIVE FIVE SEVEN WOULD IT BE
SEVEN EIGHT THREE BIGELOW AB
EIGHT EIGHT THREE DALY ALL.
TO APPROPRIATIONS AND AB TEN
SIXTY SEVEN TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU. TWO I DALY
[inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
LEVINE.
BLANCA RUBIO SALAS WOULD.
WHY THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
ITEM SEVEN A. B.?
FIVE FIFTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER
CARILLO
.
RIGHT.
A GOOD SIGNAL [inaudible]
MUSICAL CHAIRS [inaudible]
MORE [inaudible]
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
STAFF I'VE MISSED YOU.
THAT'S ENOUGH IN THIS COMMITTEE
ANYMORE.
BUT I WANTED TO I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB.
FIVE FIFTY SIX THE BILL THAT
WILL HELP IMPROVE OUTER
EXPERIENCES FOR DISADVANTAGED
YOUTH AND IMPROVE THE OVERALL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO LAST
YEAR'S AB TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN
WHICH THIS COMMITTEE HAS SEEN
BEFORE AND ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND MADE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR SOUTH LAST YEAR.
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
DISADVANTAGED URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
LITTLE TO NO ACCESS TO OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES.
EVEN WHEN THEY LIVE MINUTES AWAY
FROM THE SPACES FOR EXAMPLE IN
MY DISTRICTS OF IN MY DISTRICT
THE LA PARK SCORE WAS 41% FOR
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN LA.
WHO DID NOT HAVE IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO PARKS A UCLA IN SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY STUDY
FOUND THAT THE LACK OF
TRANSPORTATION?
HI ACOSTA PARKING AND LIMITED
ACCOMMODATIONS POST SOME OF THE
LARGEST BARRIERS FOR COMMUNITY
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS.
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES HAVE
NUMEROUS BENEFITS FOR OUR YOUTH.
IT HAS LED TO HEALTHIER
LIFESTYLES BETTER EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES AND IMPROVEMENTS TO
THEIR OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH.
PROVIDING ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
CAN ENCOURAGE GREATER CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT UNDERSTANDING OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AND CAN
HELP FOSTER FUTURE ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP AND PROTECTION.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX WILL LAST THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY WITH
CREATING A COMMUNITY ACCESS
PROGRAM. TO ENABLE CALIFORNIANS
TO REACHING UTILIZE NATURAL
EDUCATION AND RECREATIONAL
RESOURCES.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW FOR
THE CREATION OF A GRANT PROGRAM
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR INNOVATIVE.
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
FOSTER MORE ACCESS TO THOSE WHO
ARE OFTEN DENIED THESE
EXPERIENCE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS
JOSE GONZALEZ THE FOUNDER OF
LATINO A DOORS AND ONE OF THEM
WE DON'T KNOW ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
POLICY FOR THE AUDUBON.
CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
THIS BILL.
RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING ONE IS THIS -- GOOD
MORNING TRACY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT'S MY NAME'S JOSE GONZALEZ
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE TEAM OF DOORS THAT AS A
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COURTEOUS -- AB -- FIVE
FIFTY SIX LATINO DOORS IS A
UNIQUE ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
FOUNDED HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WORKING COOPERATIVE WITH MANY OF
THE STATE -- AGENCIES AND PARKS
HYSTRIX IF FOR EXAMPLE PROVIDING
OUTER EXPERIENCES ALL THE WAY
FROM HUMBOLDT TO FAMILIES AND
KIDS DOWN TO SAN DIEGO.
AND OUR WORK IS TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE A NATIONAL COMMUNITY OF
LEADERS IN CONSERVATION OUTRAGE
CATIONS WHICH WE ARE DOING.
THE KEY THING AROUND THAT IS
THAT ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
NATURE SEEMS LIKE IT OUT TO BE A
BIRTHRIGHT FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
GIVEN THE HISTORY -- AND THE
LEADERSHIP THAT IS DEMONSTRATED
AND IT'S WOVEN THROUGH THE
LANDSCAPES MANY OF US ARE
EXTREMELY FORTUNATE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TWO OR CAN EASILY ACCESS
ECOSYSTEMS THAT PROVIDE
BIODIVERSITY HONESTLY THAT KIND
OF THE ENVY OF THE WORLD.
I AIN'T ARE WE HAVE WORLD CLASS
STATE PARKS IN NATIONAL PARKS
ICONIC COASTLINES AND THEIR
UNIQUE FLORA AND FAUNA.
AND FOR US IS IMPORTANT TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN HAVE A
CONNECTION TO THAT.
THIS IS WHY AB FIVE FIFTY SIX IS
IMPORTANT ENHANCING
DISADVANTAGED YOUTH ACCESS TO
OUR CHRIS BURY SAYS IN ORDER TO
CREATE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
OUTDOOR ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION
EXPERIENCES THAT OUR PUBLIC
LANDS IS VITAL TO CONTINUE. TO
ENSURE THAT THE NEXT GENERATION
LIKE GENERATION BEFORE IN THE
GENERATION NOW -- THEY WERE
SUPPORTING THIS GENERATION
ENVIRONMENTAL STORAGE TO
CONTINUE THE WORK TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD ON A CONSERVATION
SUCCESSES THAT WE'VE HAD IN THE
PAST.
SO IN ORDER FOR THIS TO BE A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
IT IS JUST AS CRITICAL FOR THE
REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE ACCESS
THE PLACE TO ALL DEPARTMENT AND
AGENCIES.
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AS A FOR THESE REASONS
AND OTHERS THAT THE NO DOOR
STRONG SUPPORT AB FIVE FIFTY SIX
AND EXTENT IN ITS THINK WE'LL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO FOR
LEADERSHIP ON THE MATTER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR IBOOK OKAY AT
THIS TIME WILL.
PUT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS ONE OF THE MEAT ON A
WITHOUT ABOUT IN CALIFORNIA --
WE'RE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB -- FIVE FIVE SIX FIRST OFF WE
WANT TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO. FOR TACKLING THIS
PRESSING ISSUE ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS.
SHOULD BE A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
A CALIFORNIANS BUT ESPECIALLY
FOR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES WHO
HAVE LITTLE TO NO ACCESS TO
EXPERIENCE THE OUTDOORS.
AT AUDUBON CALIFORNIA WE STRIVE
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS THROUGH CENTERS IN
CHAPTER NETWORK -- OUR CHAPTER
NETWORKS ARE SPECIFICALLY THE
WORK THAT WE DO THROUGH ONE OF
OUR CENTERS WHICH IS AN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAREERS AS A
DISTRICT.
ADEPTS PARK IS WE AIM TO INSPIRE
PEOPLE TO EXPERIENCE AND
UNDERSTAND AND CARE FOR THE
LOCAL NAY OUR NATURAL WORLD
AROUND THEM.
THIS NATURE BASED EDUCATION AND
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THAT THAT
PART DUBS PARK ARE DESIGNED TO
ENGAGE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE OUTDOOR WORLD.
AND GIVE THEM A PERSONAL STAKE
IN ITS PROTECTION BY MAKING
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES RELEVANT TO
THEIR LIVES WE UNDERSTAND THAT
HOWEVER THAT THE TRANSFORMATIVE
NATURE OF BEING EXPOSED TO THE
OUTDOORS.
OUR HE CAN BE SEEN FIRST HAND
BUT MANY MANY OF THESE FAMILIES
AND YOUNG PEOPLE --
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO EXPERIENCE THAT --
THEY THEY LACK THE RESOURCES --
MA'AM.
NOT ONLY IN WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
BUT ALSO.
WITHIN.
SURVEY XIN ORGANIZATION
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION LIKE OURS.
THAT.
THERE THERE IS NO TRANSPORTATION.
OUR DOLLARS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS AND THAT MAKES IT A
CHALLENGE FOR COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS.
THESE THINGS.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX WOULD CHANGE
THAT BY A AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO SAID. FOR BY HAVING THE
CREATION OF A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
WILL FOSTER.
MORE ACCESS TO MORE PEOPLE AND
AS WE CONTINUE TO TACKLE THESE.
THESE ISSUES RELATED TO
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING GAPS --
WE WE HOPE THAT THIS IS A FOR
ONE STEP.
IN TRYING TO GET MORE
CALIFORNIANS INTO THE OUTDOORS A
AND THAT IS WHY WE A VIRGIN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THE MOTION AND SECOND WE HAVE
OTHER FOLKS WANTING.
TO SUPPORT THE BILL MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE SILENCE ALICE
WITH THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THERESA BURKE ****
ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE BAY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING A CHAIR MEMBERS
DOUG HOUSTON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR RECREATION
PARTNERSHIP CEDAR CONSORTIUM.
CALIFORNIA PARKING WRECKED
RATIONS SOCIETIES BABY TO PARK
DISTRICTS YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL
WANTS TO KNOW THE COUNTY PARKS
ON SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
HOLLY MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GONNA BE HAVE
A SOUL AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CAM DELFINO WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT.
TRACY BYRD ATORES I'M HAPPY
AFTER INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND
ARI I IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BRIAN MEDINA ON
BEHALF OF MID PENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT FRIENDS OF
THE LA RIVER AND SAVE THE WORLD
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA ROMERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEE NO ONE ANYONE WISHING.
TO THE POSITION BRING BACK TO
DICE ANY QUESTIONS THE AUTHOR.
THIS BIGELOW WHILE BY DOCTOR
CHOI.
AGAIN THANKS TO THE OFFICE
AUTHOR FOR REASONING THE BILL.
OF A QUESTION I HAVE IS THIS
BILL YOU YOU RENT LAST YEAR.
IT WAS PRESENTED AND THEN IT GOT
AWAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THAT HE SAID.
THE GOVERNOR IN HIS VETO MESSAGE
ADDRESSED THE ISSUE OF THE FACT
THAT.
THERE'S ALREADY TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS THIS.
THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR MANY OF
THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS WERE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IS THERE.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IS THE COST FOR
THIS AND WHY DO YOU WANT TO
SINGLE OUT WHEN IT THERE'S
ALREADY A PROGRAM?
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE.
HELP US TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO WE CAN DISCUSS ISSUES ON
FISCAL IMPACT AND APPROPRIATIONS
THE THE POLICY OF THIS IS TO
ALIGN VOTER INTENT WITH PROP
SIXTY EIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE GRANT PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE
FOR TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE WHETHER
IT'S RULE URBAN AREAS LET'S
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET KIDS TO THE PLACES
THAT THEY NEED TO BE IN A LINE
ON WHAT THE VOTERS WANT. FOR
SIXTY EIGHT AND GIVEN THAT SAID
IT IT.
THERE WAS ANOTHER MEASURE THAT
CAME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE PRIOR.
AND THIS THE SAME.
ONE WHAT WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
IS AN A GROWING.
QUESTION FOR US TO FACE AS A
POLICY AS WE START PUTTING MORE
AND MORE PEOPLE INSIDE OUR PARK
SYSTEM THE PARK SYSTEM THAT'S
NEARLY ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE RED -- FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO GIVE THEM A
MEANINGFUL EXPERIENCE WHEN MANY
OF THE AREAS ARE GONNA HAVE TO
BE CLOSED BECAUSE OF SAFETY
CONCERNS AND A LACK OF FUNDING?
WE SEEM TO HAVE AGAINST THE CART
BEFORE THE HORSE WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE A SAFE PLACE
FOR THESE -- YOUTH AND
INDIVIDUALS TO GO.
TO SO IT IT'S KIND OF A DOUBLE
EDGED SWORD HERE WE WANT TO HAVE
PEOPLE EXPERIENCE IT WE WANT TO
ENJOY.
BUT WE'VE WE'VE GOT.
PROBLEMS OR ISSUES HERE TO
ADDRESS SO HOW DO YOU SEE AS
FACING THAT ISSUE WITH THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND THEIR
IMPACT THAT THIS MAY STIMULATE.
I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU ON THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PART I
THINK THAT OUR PARKS HAVE BEEN
IGNORED FOR QUITE SOME TIME --
INCLUDING OUR STATE BEACHES I'VE
BEEN TO SOME STATE BEACH OF THAT
CLEARLY NEED -- SOME HELP AND I
AND I WORRY ABOUT.
YOU KNOW -- I WENT TO ONE STATE
BEACH THE WHERE THE STEPS GOING
DOWN WERE CRACKED MADE A CEMENT
IN THE RAILING WHICH WAS -- MADE
OF IRON CLEARLY NEEDED TO BE
REPLACED SO I WORRY ABOUT THAT
TOO WHAT I'M ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT THE STATE BEACHES
ARE HAVE BECOME A LITTLE ELITE.
IN TERMS OF WHO GETS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THEM.
SO I BELIEVE THAT IF WE CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS.
AGAIN RULE IN URBAN COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
MORE COMMUNITY SUPPORT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA HAVE MORE SUPPORT
FROM CALIFORNIANS TO SAY WE NEED
TO DO.
SOMETHING TO ENSURE THAT THE
SPACES THAT WE HAVE ALLOCATED
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO ENJOY.
ARE AT THE LEVEL OF MAINTENANCE
THAT THEY THEY SHOULD BE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
DR.
YEAH MY QUESTION ALSO ALLIANCE A
SIMILAR -- TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
BIGELOW IS A CONCERN -- IN THE
NIGHT.
I HEARD DOT MANY TIMES SO WE
NEED.
MORE A MAINTENANCE AND THE
AMENITIES -- TO BE -- IS THAT
BRIDGE THE SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW IF -- PROP
SIXTY EIGHT DELLA WAS SO
ORIGINALLY INTENDED THE OF FOR
THIS OF TRANSPORTATION.
ARE. FOR YOU WITH THE OF THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
KNOWN ON WALL WAS A STAR OF THE
OR THE PURPOSES. FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WARM BUILDING
MAINTENANCE.
PROP SIXTY EIGHT WAS INTENDED
FOR A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT --
NEEDS HOWEVER THERE WAS ABOUT
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WERE ALLOCATED OR THAT.
THE VOTER INTENT WAS TO ACTUALLY
CREATE A PATHWAY TO ALLOW
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FROM
ACROSS THE STATE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO STATE RESOURCES SO ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THE THERE WAS A
SPECIFIC AMOUNT SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS UP.
TO SET ASIDE THE SPECIFIED THE
IN THAT THE BALLOT MEASURE THAT
IS CORRECT AND SO WHAT WE WANNA
DO IS MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL
AND ITS INTENT AND PURPOSE
ALIGNS.
WITH THE VOTER INTENTION WELL
HOW HOW MUCH IS A CREATED A
THREE TO SELL PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOR
PROP SIXTY EIGHT OF THEM. TWO
SURE TO WANNA -- THANK YOU FOR
LOOKING FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EARN TO WEIGH IN HERE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND FEDERAL NOT
BEHALF LOOKING OR DOORS -- AND
OTTOMAN WHEN TWO HATS SPECIFIC
TO THE PROP SIXTY QUESTIONS THAT
I DON'T HAVE BEEN RAISED BY A BY
THE BY THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT --
WANNA SPECIFY TWO THINGS IS THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE LAST
YEAR -- TALKED ABOUT THE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
THAT WAS MADE AVAILABLE IN PROP --
SIXTY EIGHT FORTY SIMILAR KINDS
OF OF OF IDEAS -- BUT
PHENOMENALLY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS OF THE TWO
AND SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION WAS
FOR THE STATE WHAT PART PROGRAM
WHICH IS FULLY INTENDED TO
DEVELOP PARKS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
IN COMMUNITIES -- WHEREAS I'M
CONCEPTS LIKE THE ONE THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN IN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BILL ARE ABOUT TAKING
FOLKS OUT FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES --
TO OUR NATURAL SPACES BEING ABLE
TO VISIT THE MOUNTAINS BEING UP
TO HIS THE DESERT'S THAT THE
COAST -- AND THEN SECOND -- DO
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT WE'VE
BEEN IN THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS
ACTUALLY -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS WEIGHED IN TO SAY
THAT BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN
AROUND -- USING BOND DOLLARS FOR
PROGRAM COST THEY THEY'RE SIMPLY
NOT GONNA ALLOW PROGRAMS TO MOVE
FORWARD -- USING THOSE FUNDS
FROM FROM PROP -- SIXTY EIGHT
THE EMPHASIS FROM FROM THEIR
RESPECTIVE NEEDS TO BE ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY.
I'M SO AS A RESULT WHAT WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED HERE IS SOMETHING
THAT IS IT IS VERY MUCH IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE INTENT OF OF
THE VOTERS WHEN THE IMPROVE PROP.
SIXTY EIGHT BUT TAKING IT
OUTSIDE OF JUST THAT ONE STATURE
IN THE BOND LANGUAGE AND
APPLYING IT TO THE ENTIRETY OF
RESOURCES AGENCY -- WITH THE
HOPE OF COURSE AS THIS MOVES ON
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE THE
CONTINUE DISCUSSION ABOUT
POTENTIALLY IDENTIFYING
ADDITIONAL FUNDS SOURCES WHETHER
THEY BE SPECIAL FUNDS ARE
GENERAL FUND -- TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE ON ON ON ON THE
OBJECTIVES AND GOALS THAT ARE
THERE IN THE BILL -- SO IT HAPPY
TO ANSWER ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
THANKS FOR BRING HERE I THOUGHT
THAT I GOT AN ANSWER BUT YOU YOU
YOU.
IT DIDN'T QUITE CLEAR BY BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING
SETTING THE STAGE NOW FOR WHAT I
WAS WORRIED ABOUT.
AND AND THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
WHY MY WORRY IS.
WE ARE NOT BUDGETING THE NINE
HUNDRED TO A BILLION DOLLARS OF
BACK FEEL FOR THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BECAUSE WE CONTINUE
TO CREATE NEW PROGRAMS THAT
BECAUSE A DRAIN.
AND MISS GRILL IS.
TRYING TO DO A AN ADMIRABLE
THING HERE AND AND THAT'S GET
THE YOU GET THE PEOPLE INTO THE
PARK.
BUT IT CASA COMES AT A COST
BECAUSE NOW THAT COST WILL BE
ACTS AND IT'LL BE LESS MONEY
COMING FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THAT WILL REDUCE THE ABILITY FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO FIND OR GET
MORE MONEY. TO TO THE PARKS TO
TO RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES AT THAT
LOCAL LEVEL IF WE CONTINUE TO
CREATE PROGRAMS THAT ARE COSTING
WILL CONTINUE TO SEE A A
DEGRADATION.
OF THE SERVICES THAT WERE ABLE
TO PROVIDE.
THAT'S MY CONCERN AND I THINK
IT'S A LEGITIMATE CONCERN THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN FACED
BY THIS COMMITTEE.
SINCE THIS IS A POLICY THAT SETS
THE STAGE FOR THE APPROPRIATION
ACTION.
I I WOULD LOVE HIM.
I WOULD SUGGEST LOOKING AT AT AT
THE SLIMMEST BIGELOW.
AND THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY A A
A A DEMOCRATIC PERSPECTIVE BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE BEEN
WAYNE IN MY MIND FOR A BIT --
NOW AND THAT IS THE IDEA THAT
SOMETIMES WE REDUCE TAXES ON
BUSINESSES BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
IT CREATES MORE ECONOMIC REVENUE.
SELF IF WE CREATE PROGRAMS THAT
BRING MORE PEOPLE INTO THESE
PARKS WE ARE ALSO CREATING
REVENUE IN TERMS OF THE PARKING
THAT THEY PAY ANY ENTRANCES ANY
FEES.
BUT WE PASSED A LAW LAST YEAR
THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWS STATE PARKS
TO NOW SELL MERCHANDISE TO HELP
OFFSET THOSE COSTS WHICH WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR.
SO WE'VE BEEN STEADILY WORKING
AT WAYS TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
MAKE SURE THAT THAT OUR OUR
STATE PARKS AND RESOURCES ARE
ACTUALLY MAINTAINED.
A IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT BUT WE'RE HOPING THAT
IF WE ACTUALLY GET PEOPLE TO
THESE PLACES AND THEY'RE ABLE TO
SEE THE BEAUTY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE CAN CREATE A PRIORITY AS TO
WHAT THIS IS.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT AND AND I
WOULD LOOK AT IT THE SAME WAY IF
WE REDUCE.
TAXES WE STIMULATE THE ECONOMY
WHICH CREATES AN ECONOMIC GROWTH
AND A BILL WHICH IN TURN
REVOLVES A CIRCLE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT GETTING FUNDING
FOR PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD EVEN
PUT THE GAS OR HAVE THE VEHICLE.
THERE'S A MECHANISM FOR CREATING
A A A PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM FOR THEM TO GET THERE
LIKELY THEY DON'T HAVE ANY.
PARKING ISSUES LIKELY THEY DON'T
HAVE MUCH IF ANY MONEY TO SPEND
FOR THOSE RESOURCE THOSE.
FACILITIES INSIDE THE PARKS I I
WOULD GRANT THAT THAT THAT'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STE.
YOUTH OR INDIVIDUALS TO GO TO
THESE PARTS I'M WITH YOU ON THAT
I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT.
THAT OCCUR BUT WHAT I REALLY
MISTER CHAIR THINK IS MORE WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THIS FROM A MORE
HOLISTIC.
STANDPOINT AGAIN WHAT COMES
FIRST.
THE CARD FOR THE HORSE WE JUST
GOT TO FIGURE ALL THAT OUT I'M
I'M WITH YOU LIKE 90% THE WAYS
JUST ONE LITTLE ELEMENT HERE
THAT'S AYE LOOKING.
ABSOLUTELY WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM A SUMMER PERSON.
THANK YOU AND I'M NOT GOING TO
MAKE THIS ABOUT ECONOMICS BUT
ABOUT JUSTICE AND THE REALITY IS
WHETHER YOU LIVE IN A RURAL%
COMMUNITY AREN'T IRVINE
COMMUNITY WHETHER YOU'RE RICH OR
POOR WE'RE ALL PAYING FOR THIS
BOND.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT THESE
PARKS ARE BEING USED WITH OR
WITHOUT THAT MAINTAINS BUT IT'S
ONLY BEING USED BY FOUR TWO CAN
AFFORD. TO GET THEMSELVES ARE
THE WE ARE ALL PAYING FOR THESE
PARTS THE RESPECTIVE A LETTER
INCOME LOOKS LIKE AT THE IN THE
DAY.
AND AS A BY JUSTICE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE PAYING FOR THESE
PARTS AND COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
PARKS.
AGAIN EVERY REMOVE THOSE
BARRIERS IT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE
WILL DO A LITTLE BIT OF MATH FOR
YOU IT'S A SMALL PERCENTAGE WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND SO YOU STILL HAVE THE BULK
OF THE MONEY OVER 95% OF THE
MONEY TO GO TOWARDS THINGS LIKE
MAINTENANCE TO ENSURE THAT AT
THE SAME TIME WE HAVE JUSTICE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE.
YOU STILL HAVE PEOPLE USING THE
PARK WHO PAID FOR IT BUT THE
DOLLARS THAT THEY PUT IN
PLEASANT DOLLARS AT COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE PUT IN BUT ARE NOT
ENJOYING THE PARK.
AND SETS ABOUT ENSURING THAT IN
THE PROCESS WE CAN MULTI TASK.
AND MAYBE AS A WOMAN I JUST I'M
GOOD AT MULTI TASKING -- AND WE
COULD DO BOTH AT THE SAME TIME
IT'S A SMALL TINY INVESTMENT TO
ENSURE WE HAVE JUSTICE IN THIS
PROCESS.
AND SO I APPRECIATE WHERE THIS
BILL IS GOING I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVE BEEN SIGNED AND HAVING MY
COMMUNITY PARTAKE IN THESE
ACTIVITIES.
NOT ONLY ARE WE PARK PART OF MY
DISTRICT AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE
NEED TO ADDRESS IN THIS PLAN
ALSO HELPS WITH THAT.
BUT WE ARE ALSO NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GOOD STEWARDS OF
THE ENVIRONMENT OF AND WHAT WE
LOVE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IDLE
SPEECHES THOSE MOUNTAINS.
ON INTO WE NEED TO GET US OUT
THERE AND AT IN A DAY I DON'T
HAVE A SINGLE MOUNTAIN AND EVEN
THOUGH THAT HAVE A POSITIVE
SLOPE OF ANY SORT OF MY DISTRICT --
AND I DEFINITELY DON'T HAVE A
BEACH.
AND SO I APPRECIATE WE'RE GOING
WITH THIS I THINK IT'S A SMALL
INVESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE A JUST PROCESS AS ARE DOING
THE DIFFERENT MEANINGS THAT IS
SO BADLY NEEDED TO THAT WE ARE
ALL FAITH.
AND AT THOSE.
FIVE THANK YOU.
I THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YOU
SEE NO.
ONE I'D LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AT NEW WE'VE DISCUSSED THE BOND --
THAT WAS -- AUTHORED BY SENATOR
DE LEóN.
AND FOUR FOUR BILLION FOUR POINT
ONE BILLION I THINK WAS THE
TOTAL THE BOND THAT THIS ISSUE
THAT WAS PUT FORWARD CREATIVELY --
TO CREATE -- PROGRAMS FOR AXIS I
THINK WAS BRILLIANT -- I'D LIKE
FOR US TO MAY BE ALSO IN THE
SHORT TERM ADDRESSED THE ISSUE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS PUTTING FORWARD TO MANY OF
THE LOCAL GROUPS AND
ORGANISATIONS MAYBE IT'S A
LETTER THAT WE ALL CAN SIGN ON
TO LETTING THEM KNOW THAT --
THAT WAS APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
IN OF COURSE THIS BILLS JUST
ALIGNING YOU KNOW THAT EFFORT --
BUT I I LINE MY SELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE --
CRISTINA GARCIA AND PROUD -- TO
A CA TO THE BILL LIGHT A WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE BY OUR COLLEAGUE
OF MR BIGELOW -- BUT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY HERE
NOT ENOUGH -- TO DO THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND I I TO THE
BELIEVE LIKE I THINK THAT.
THE A DEMOCRAT WITH THE
ENTREPRENEURIAL PERSPECTIVE --
MISS CARILLO THAT YEAH WE KNOW
WHAT WE INVEST MONEY THERE.
THAT IT WILL BREED MORE MONEY
RIGHT MORE VISITORS TO THE PARK
PEOPLE WILL SPEND MONEY.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
ALSO CREATE THE GREATER
ADVOCATES -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT CYCLE OF INVESTING IN TO
OUR BEACHES ARE MOUNTAINS YOU
KNOW A CONTINUES TO BE.
A HIGH PRIORITY SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING.
THIS BILL FORWARD -- DO WE HAVE
A MOTION -- A MOTION AND A
SECOND AT THE CLOSING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD JUST SAY THIS I
I GREW UP IN THE IN THE BOYLE
HEIGHTS EAST LA COMMUNITY --
CLOSE TO THE BEACH ABOUT AN HOUR.
OR TWO DAYS DEPENDING ON TRAFFIC --
BUT WHEN I WAS LITTLE I WOULD
TAKE A I WOULD TAKE A SCHOOL BUS
THAT THE LA COUNTY SUPERVISORS
WOULD PROVIDE OUT OF A LOCAL
PARK COST A DOLLAR MY SISTER AND
I AND WE WOULD TAKE I WAS LIKE A
SATURDAY MORNING COSTS A DOLLAR.
WE JUMP ON THE BUS GO TO THE
BEACH ENJOY A DAY AT THE BEACH
AND THEN COME BACK.
ON MY PARENTS WORKED TWO JOBS
THEY COULDN'T REALLY TAKE US ON
A WEEKEND.
BUT IT INSTILLED IN ME AND MY
SISTERS THIS LOVE OF NATURE AND
THIS LOVE OF THE BEACH AND THAT.
WE PARTICIPATED N. BEACH
CLEANUPS WE PARTICIPATED IN THEM
AND A LOT OF THINGS THAT
ACTUALLY -- MOTIVATED US TO
LEARN ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
I HOPE THAT THAT IS WHAT WE
CREATE HERE.
THAT WE GET YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THE SPACES
TO LOVE OPEN SPACE TO LOVE
NATURE TO LOVE THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND TO BE GOOD STEWARDS OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I. BUT WE THINK YOU
WILL MOTIONS SECOND EYES WERE
ROQUE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
I'M GONNA NOT VOTE -- UNDERSTATE
APPROACH NOW GIVE US TIME TO
KIND OF GIVE US A LITTLE BIT.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHU <c.cyan>WI DALLY [inaudible]</c>
FRIEDMAN.
TINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
CHOLERA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOOD
[inaudible] SIX THE OPEN FOR
THE MEMBERS THANK.
MEMBER ADAM GRAY [inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHT MORNING WALK.
GOOD MORNING MR SEC THE BILL
DOES ENJOY IT TO PASS YOU'RE
RIGHT TO FIND COMMITTEE NATURE
[inaudible]
CLOSING REMARKS.
AT THE TIME OF THE RESULT I GIVE
YOU REAL -- A SHORT SUMMARY THE
BILL HI THIS BILL INSTRUCT YOU
W. R. TO BASICALLY LOOK AT
CLIMATE CHANGE LOOK AT OUR WATER
STORAGE CAPACITY STATEWIDE --
AND COME BACK AND MAKE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO HOW WE
BEST ADAPT TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE -- DRINKING
WATER FOR COMMUNITIES -- WATER
FOR AGRICULTURE WATER FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT ETCETERA SO THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION DANCE BACK
FASTER AYE VOTE.
OR ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK A IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OF A MOTION SECOND [inaudible]
OSCAR ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE.
GARCIA AYE GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW AYE BIGELOW AYE CHOI.
CHOICE I TO DALLY FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA -- CI GLORIA.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS WOULD.
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS AT
A MIXTURE YOU GOT.
PEOPLE CALLING OTHER -- MEMBERS
TO PRESENT ON THEIR BILLS.
ALONG WITH THE MANAGER TO SEE IF
I'M WHICH SHOWS UP OTHERWISE ALL.
PRESENT
[inaudible]
YEAH
.
IT IS NOT [inaudible]
WHICH MR GARCIA MISTER CHAIRMAN
A. B. FOUR FOUR EIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE.
TO IT WILL BEGIN BY PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY EIGHT
THAT WILL ALLOW OWNERS OF STOCK
PONDS WITH THE CAPACITY OF NO
MORE THAN. TEN ACRE FEET TO PAY
A ONE TIME FEE TO OBTAIN A VALID
WATER RIGHT IN THE FORM OF A
CERTIFICATE.
THE CERTAINTY ASSOCIATED WITH
THE FEE WILL ENCOURAGE
COMPLIANCE IMPROVE THE EFFICIENT
ADMINISTRATION OF THE WATER
SAVE IMPORTANT HABITAT.
IN RURAL FARMLAND AT THE TWO
WITNESSES A WITH ME THAT WILL
TESTIFY.
VERY BRIEFLY ON ON THIS MATTER.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
THIS GARCIA A SECOND BY THE
CHAIR.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THE FIRST
WITNESS.
PLEASE.
THANK YOU JACK RICE A RANCHER
FROM HUMBLE COUNTY AND A MEMBER
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO LOOK AT THE
EXISTING SYSTEM FOR REGISTERING
STOCK PONDS AND FIND WAYS TO
IMPROVE IT MAKE IT MORE
EFFICIENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT A. B. -- FOR
FORTY EIGHT DOES THESE ARE STOCK
FUNDS ARE SMALL IMPOUNDMENTS
THERE'S A LITTLE DAMP FEW FEET
HIGH SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
EIGHTEEN MILLION ACRES OF
RANGELAND IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY CATCH WATER IN THE WINTER
AND HOLD IT OVER TO THE DRY
SEASON WHICH IS PROVIDES
IMPORTANT.
AGRA NAMIK BENEFITS KEEPS CATTLE
OUT IN THE AREA IN THE LANDSCAPE
SO THEY CAN BETTER UTILIZE FEED
AND IT ALSO PROVIDES SOME
IMPORTANT TO ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS IT'S WATER TO DRINK FOR
ALL KINDS OF CRITTERS DURING THE
DRY SEASON AS WE KNOW WATERS.
THE LIFE -- LIFEBLOOD
PARTICULARLY IN IN THE DRY
SEASON WHICH IS A LITTLE HARD TO
IMAGINE I GUESS RIGHT NOW BUT IT
WILL COME BACK AGAIN.
AND IT'S ALSO HABITAT FOR SOME
IMPORTANT AMPHIBIANS.
IN ADDITION -- FIRE SUPPRESSION
IS THE KEY.
OF VALUE TO THIS ARE OFTEN
UTILIZED IN WILDFIRES BY
HELICOPTERS PARTICULARLY.
AND ALSO IT -- IT'S ANOTHER WAY
TO SLOW WATER ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
FOR CALIFORNIANS WERE WORKING ON
OUR GROUNDWATER SYSTEMS AND IN
MY OPINION THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE A RESOURCE IS
GOOD FOR AGRICULTURE AND THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE CHALLENGES THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ISN'T WORKABLE.
IT'S UNNECESSARILY EXPENSIVE AND
BURDENSOME FOR LANDOWNERS AND
FOR THE STATE.
BASICALLY THE COST BENEFIT RATIO
IS OUT OF WHACK IF YOU WILL.
THIS STATE SPENDS TOO MUCH TIME
AND MONEY DOING WHAT THE
REGISTRATIONS IN THE LAND OWNERS
DO THE SAME TO THE POINT WHERE --
IT MIGHT IN SOME CASES IT MAY
MAKE MORE SENSE FOR THEM TO JUST
TEAR AMOUNT.
SO AB FOR FORTY EIGHT SEEKS TO
BETTER ALIGN THE COSTS AND
BENEFITS FOR BOTH FOR THE STATE
AND FOR THE LANDOWNER.
IT'S GONNA ADDRESS WITH INITIAL
FILING FEE AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO
RENEW IT ALL THE TIME AND ALSO
IT'LL SIMPLIFY AND STREAMLINE
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
THERE ARE SOME AMENDMENTS SOME.
WE ARE TALKING [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS --
DOES THE OTHER -- PRESENTER ONE
SAY ANYTHING DO ANYTHING MISTER
OVER.
WITH I JUST AN OLD FIELD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WERE SPONSORING THE
BILL JUST WANNA TAKE THAT THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE AND WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT ANY
ISSUES.
OUTSTANDING ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED
MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHERS WISHING TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE.
IN SUPPORT.
YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MERION WARMER DOWN FOR
ALL COUNTY REPRESENTED AS A
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE THANK YOU.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
DANNY BERKELEY CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU -- ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING CAM DELFINO WHAT --
WITH DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE -- I
WILL OFFER GETTING UP HERE
BECAUSE ONE OF OUR REPORTS IS
ACTUALLY CITED IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AND THAT IS WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF STOCK PONDS
FOR WILDLIFE AND IN FACT.
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
RANGE WITH THE RANCHING
COMMUNITY -- AS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA RANGE LAND
CONSERVATION COALITION.
AND SO THAT SO.
I THINK WHAT ARE OPPOSITION
THOUGH IS BASED ON THE FACT THAT
THE BILL IS PRESENTLY WRITTEN IS
A BIT SWEEPING -- CERTAINLY I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE ASSOCIATED
WITH THE COST AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED HOWEVER WHEN THE BILL
WAS PUT TOGETHER IT ALSO.
EXEMPTED ALL REVIEW -- FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE BOARD IN TERMS OF AND
THE ABILITY.
TO MONITOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
COMPLIANCE IS IN ORDER AND SO
WELL WE'RE NOT ADVOCATING FOR
BURDENSOME PROCESS WE WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE THE AT LEAST SOME
MINIMAL AMOUNT OF REVIEW.
BECAUSE WHILE STOCK PLANS DO
PROVIDE A LOT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFIT OF FOR READ LIKE A FROG
IN CALIFORNIA TIGER SALAMANDER
THEY ARE SOMETIMES PRODUCE
THROUGH DIVERSIONS -- AND WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE F. W. SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THE DIVERSIONS AT
LEAST -- TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
NOT IMPACTING STREAMS -- THAT
HAVE IMPORTANT FISH POPULATIONS
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WITH THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL WITH THE WATER UGH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD.
AND BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD BUT HAD TO GET UP AND
EXPRESS HER POSITION AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I KNOW
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND AND THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL IS ALWAYS
WILLING AS WELL AS A SPONSOR
WILLING TO WORK WITH -- FOLKS TO
TRY TO GET THE BEST A BILL
PROCESS.
PRESENTED.
I ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
OF THE AUTHOR.
SEEING NONE WE HAD A MOTION BY
MS GARCIA SECONDED BY THE CHAIR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EMOTIONAL THAT WAS IT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE NICEST OPPOSITIONS I'VE
HEARD -- IN MY FOUR YEARS ARE
NOT ONLY COMING VERY WILLING TO
WORK WITH THEM ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU YES FOR BEST REVIVAL.
WHICH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL NOW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA BY GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
JELLY FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA KALRA.
COLOR I LEVINE LEVINE I BLANCA
RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS SALAS I
WOULD.
WOOD I AM NOT SURE BUT WAS A
WITNESSES.
THAT BILLS OUT BUT WE'LL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
AS CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
YOUR SECOND BILL AB SO FIND A
THAT.
WAS CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY PERCENT
A. B..
SIX FIFTY EIGHT THIS BILL
CREATES A NEW PROCESS WITH WHICH
WILL ALLOW THE STATE WATER BOARD
TISSUE FIBER TEMPORARY.
URGENT PERMIT URGENCY PERMIT THE
PERMIT WILL ALLOW GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES.
LOCAL AGENCIES TO APPLY FOR THIS
NEW PERMIT AND DIVERT WATER TO
UNDERGROUND STORAGE DURING I
FLOWS ADDING ANOTHER TOOL FOR
THE COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WERE
FACING DRASTIC CHANGES DUE TO
SEGMENTATION.
AS WE KNOW MANY COMMUTERS ACROSS
THE STATE ARE FACING CHALLENGES
OF IMPLEMENTING SIGMA.
AB FIVE SIX FIVE EIGHT WILL HELP
COMMUNITIES IN USERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
TEMPERMENT SIGMA BY USING
RECHARGE TO ITS FULLEST
POTENTIAL.
MORE FREQUENT AND SEVERE
DROUGHTS COMBINED WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SIGMAR GOING TO
VASTLY CHANGE THE LANDSCAPE. FOR
FARMING AND URBAN COMMUNITIES IF
WE DON'T.
ACT ADEQUATELY PREPARED THE BILL
PRESENTS OVER A YEAR WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS STARTING WITH
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE WHICH
HAS -- WAS HEARD AND PASSED OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
ALTHOUGH TWENTY SIX FOR A STALL
ON SENATE FLOOR CONVERSATIONS
DID CONTINUE -- DURING THE
WINTER AT TO ADDRESS TECHNICAL
CONCERNS BY NUMBER OF INTEREST
GROUPS STAKEHOLDERS CONTINUE TO
MEET AND THERE ARE PLANNED
AMENDMENTS WHICH OUTLINED IN
THIS ANALYSIS.
THE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE REMOVING
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL ANY
PROTECTION FOR EDUCATED.
DECATUR BASINS CLARIFICATIONS
FOR THE ROLE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE.
AND ENSURING THAT THE PUBLIC UP
PROCESS WILL BE HERE TO DURING
PUBLIC MEETINGS AND PROCEDURES.
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS HERE TO TESTIFY
THAT IT BE KNOWN AS THE
CESSATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR RESPECT
AS RIVAL.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT YES GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADAM CAN
NOTICE ON BEHALF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES -- AND
WE ARE HERE -- IN A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL AS
THE COMMITTEE -- AND HOUSES
HIGHLIGHTS AND AS AS THE SOME
MEMBERS STATED -- WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR QUITE
SOME TIME SINCE LAST YEAR --
BEEN WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA IS OFFICE THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND OUR MEMBERS -- OVER
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY PLUS A PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES TO TRY TO COME TO
A CONSENSUS.
ON GROUNDWATER RECHARGE -- WHAT
WE HAVE AGREED ON IS IS -- THAT
SECTION ONE OF THE BILL SHOULD
BE STRICKEN -- AND THAT'S THE
SECTION THAT DEALS WITH
BENEFICIAL USE AND GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE -- AS YOU SAW EARLIER
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER ADMINS --
DEL THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE NOT YET TO COME TO A
CONSENSUS ON ALTHOUGH WE ARE
HAPPY TO TALK WAS HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S AN
IMPORTANT.
ONE I'M WHAT WE DO AGREE ON IS
IS REALLY WHAT IS -- CONTAINED
IN THIS BILL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THAT ARE PROPOSED.
AND THAT IS THE CREATION OF A
TEMPORARY PERMIT FOR GROUND
WATER RECHARGE FIVE YEARS.
IN THIS CASE -- IN WHICH DURING
HIGH FLOW EVENTS WATER SYSTEM
WATER AGENCIES COULD TAKE WATER
OFF OF A SYSTEM AND AND USE THAT
FOR GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT WE
HAVE AGREED ON AND THOUGH IT MAY
NOT ADDRESS EVERYBODY'S --
ISSUES WITH THEIR BASINS WE
THINK IT'S A GOOD STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION SO WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS -- BILL
AND VERY VERY -- THANKFUL THAT
THE SOME MEMBER HAS HAS AGREED
TO MOVE FORWARD [inaudible]
NEXT PRESENTER.
I WILL GO WILL GO TO THE
AUDIENCE ANYWAY WOULD ANYONE
WISHING TO ADDRESS -- THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE.
STEP FORWARD.
ARE YOU IN SUPPORT.
YOU'RE KIND OF IN A CLINIC
TWEENER OKAY SO LET ME TO GO TO
LET ME DO THIS WAY.
ON ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
WE HAVE NO SUPPORT WE HAVE
SUPPORT.
YOU ARE SUPPORT.
RENDON READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL SITE
TO SUPPORT BUT WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE I THINK YOU.
WINNERS.
DOES ANYONE IN BETWEEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER DOWN WITH RC RC WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THE MEASURE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AS WE SORT THROUGH.
THE DIFFICULTIES AS WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THIS MORNING THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING PUBLIC GARCIA WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND WE
ARE ALSO NEUTRON THE BILL BUT WE
DID IN THE FINAL VERSION OPPOSE
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE LAST
YEAR BECAUSE THE CONCERNED OVER
THE BENEFITS YOU USE.
THE COMMITMENT TO TAKE SECTION
TWELVE FORTY TWO OUT HELPS A LOT
WITH THAT CONCERNED -- SO CAN WE
NGUYEN.
I RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO
ACCELERATE GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
PROJECTS WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH AUTHOR.
AND THE STAFF AND THE WATER
BOARD GOING FOR IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORNING GAINING BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU -- WE ARE
IN SUPPORT AND CONCEPT LOOK
FORWARD TO THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE BELIEVE ARE COMING FORWARD
AND WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST SO
WE'RE CLEAR IT'S A. B. SIX FIVE
EIGHT SO THERE'S NO CONFUSION
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT THAT WANTS TO
ADDRESSES.
OR OPPOSITION JUST WANT TO BE
STE WE HAD A LOT OF WINTERS A
WINNING BUT HE BE CONFUSED.
SAYING THAT BRING IT BACK TO THE
BODY ANY QUESTIONS -- BY MEMBERS.
OKAY I DIDN'T THINK SO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL SO WE
HAVE A CLOSE COULD WE HAVE A
MOTION.
THIS GARCIA MISTER SALAS SECONDS.
THERE WAS NO QUESTIONS.
JUST GOING AROUND THE ROOM WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW I'M GETTING A OF STAYING
FOR NOW I WANT TO SEE THAT FINAL
LANGUAGE.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE GONNA
WORK ON ALL OF THOSE DETAILS ALL
I KNOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
CHOI MORNING CHOI NOT VOTING
CHIU.
CHIU I DALY.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA
[inaudible]
CHOLERA.
LEVINE HI LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE.
SALAS SALAS I WOULD.
WOOD I YEAH.
THE BILL IS OUT WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL GIVE A SECOND HERE FOR THE
CHAIR TO COME BACK TO THE WHAT'S
NEXT.
OKAY.
ITEM.
TWELVE IS THAT MISS WORK
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR DIRECTS THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO ESTABLISH A
FRESH WATER.
AND S. DURING HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOM PROGRAM. TO COORDINATE THE
ACTIONS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM TOXINS.
PRODUCED BY THESE BLOOMS.
NOW DI ARE AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF MANY ECO SYSTEMS
HOWEVER CERTAIN.
TYPES OF OUR GUY -- PRODUCE
TOXINS INCLUDING LIVER AND YOUR
TOXINS THESE TOXINS HAVE MADE
CHILDREN WHO.
PLAY IN BLOOM PLATED.
BLOOM POLLUTED WATER SEC.
AND HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY LINKED TO
A NUMBER OF PAT AND SEE OUR
DEATHS.
MULTI BODIES OF WATER ARE
CURRENTLY IMPAIRED INCLUDING --
LECTURE BELL IN MY DISTRICT THE
MULTI YEAR BLOOM AT LAKE SHOULD
BOW HAS POISONED AND KILLED AT
LEAST THREE DOGS WHO.
DRANK I SWAM IN THE WATER.
I HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THESE MESSAGE
[inaudible]
HERE'S OUR MATT BRAWL THE CHIEF
STEWARD THE CHIEF FOR STEWART
CHIP FOR THE EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARKS DISTRICT.
THE BILL.
MOST OF THE SECOND AND THE THIRD.
ONE OKAY I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE TO SPEAK TO LOG.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY -- SO I'M BEGIN MATT GROW
ALL THE TEACHERS TO REJECT THESE
ARE REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT --
THE DISTRICT MAINTAINS A DIVERSE
SYSTEM OF REGIONAL PARKS AND
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WITH
OVER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
VISITORS PER YEAR WHO ENJOY
FISHING KAYAKING SWIMMING AND
OTHER OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES IN OUR
SEVENTY THREE REGIONAL PARKS.
WE MANAGE NINE FRESHWATER LAKES
AND FIVE THESE LIKE RED
RECREATIONAL SWIMMING BOATING
AND FISHING OPPORTUNITIES -- SO
SB SAY THERE HAVE BEEN THESE
TOXIC BLOOM STARTING SINCE --
TWO TWENTY FOURTEEN AND ONE
SEVERE WHEN -- WITH THREE DOG
THIS AT ONE OF OUR LAKES AT LAKE
SEBAGO -- AND SO WE HAVE A A
VERY -- DETAILED A MONITORING
PROGRAM AND IF FOR POSTING PRESS
RELEASES -- AND CONTACTED MEDIA
OUTLETS AND POSTING STATE
ADVISORIES WE WRITE WE RELY
HEAVILY ON THE STATE WATER BOARD
CENTER BACK PERIOD HARMFUL ALBUM
NETWORK FOR RESOURCES IN AND HOW
WE DO THOSE POSTINGS.
AND TO HAVE THE BEST SCIENTIFIC
GUIDANCE A AND R. MANAGER
PROGRAMS.
SO THIS THE LEGISLATION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US BECAUSE
IT HELPS -- REINFORCED THAT
GUIDES PROVIDE DEDICATED
RESOURCES -- TO DOING THAT
RESEARCH AND GUIDANCE OF IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL FOR US THE GUNS
AND HAS NOT BEEN HEALTH AFFECTS
THE REMEDIATION METHODS. TO
REDUCE BLOOM FORMATION AND
REALLY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND BEST
MAN TO PRACTICE AS A CONDITIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
REALLY THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
THIS AND WOULD JUST REITERATE
THERE WERE STRONG ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORTER.
OF FOR ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FROM THE STATE WATER BOARD.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
INDIVIDUAL ONE SPEAKING FAVOR
THE BILL ON THE CHAIR MEMBERS
PAT RAN WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IT'S A
GOOD PUBLIC SAFETY BILL ME
KIRCHER SUPPORT THANK YOU. THREE
SPRING WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AS WELL AS HEAL THE BAY
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SEE NO ONE HE
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
GOVERNMENT MOTION AND A SECOND
TO CLOSING THE COMMA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THIS HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
LAST FOUR ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW HI BIGELOW AYE CHOI.
CHOICE I CHOOSE.
CHIU I DALY FRIEDMAN.
I CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
WOULD I SIX TEN WHAT WE'VE GOT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS IT OKAY
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
WE HAVE -- FEW MORE BILLS FOR
LIST HERE.
WHAT'S GOING TO ONE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A FEW MONTHS AT THE
CENTER.
THE ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN ELEVEN
BY SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
CREATES A NEW OFFICE ABOUT A
RECREATION FOR CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A CONCEPT THAT MIGHT
SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU MISTER
CHAIR BECAUSE IT WAS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE OF THE LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR IN THE FORM OF AB
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN BY MR CHAIR.
AND BEFORE THAT A. B. NINE OH
SEVEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN RECOGNIZES THAT THE
OUTDOOR RECREATION ECONOMY IS
TREMENDOUS IN OUR STATE OVER
NINETY TWO BILLION DOLLARS COMES
INTO OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE OF
OUTDOOR RECREATION SPENDING IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
AND A DIRECTLY CREATES MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY THOUSAND
JOBS.
A NEW OFFICE ABOUT -- RECREATION
WILL HELP CREATE NEW ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA AND
HARNESS THE CREATIVITY AND
INNOVATION IN THE FIELD.
IT WILL COLLABORATE WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
AND PROMOTE BUSINESS RELATED
PROGRAMS TO THE OUTDOOR
RECREATION INDUSTRY.
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT PROGRAM OR
THE NEW EMPLOYMENT CREDIT
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO RETAIN AND
GROW OUR OUTDOOR RECREATION
BUSINESS.
AND IT WILL GATHER IN USE DATA
TO HELP RECREATION PROVIDERS AND
RESOURCE MANAGERS PLANNED FOR
EMERGENCY EMERGING TRENDS AND
IDENTIFY KEY OPPORTUNITIES AND
STRATEGIES TO EXPAND ACCESS.
AN OFFICE ABOUT DOOR RECREATION
WILL LOOK BROADER THAN ONE TYPE
OF LAND MANAGER IT WILL SET A
WIDE DEEP TABLE FOR LOTS OF
PLAYERS.
CORPORATE NGOS COMMUNITY GROUPS
PUBLIC AGENCIES EXCEPT TRIP TO
BE PART OF A STATEWIDE
DISCUSSION OF WHAT OUR
PRIORITIES IN PLAN SHOULD BE FOR
SUPPORTING IN GROWING THIS MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR AT OUTDOOR
RECREATION ECONOMY IN CALIFORNIA.
ELEVEN OTHER STATES HAVE OFFICES
ABOUT OR RECREATION OR EXECUTIVE
LEVEL POSITIONS FOCUSED ON THEIR
STATE'S OUTDOOR RECREATION
SECTORS.
SO IT'S A GROWING TREND WERE
CALIFORNIA BEING THE LARGEST
OUTDOOR RECREATION ECONOMY IN
THE NATION IS NOTICEABLY ABSENT.
WE'VE ALSO PART OF THE VISION
BEHIND THIS OFFICE BEFORE AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CHAIR AND
ALL OF YOU I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO MAKING IT A REALITY THIS YEAR.
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN OUR NASA AHMED
OUTDOOR PROGRAMS AND OUTREACH
MANAGER PUTS TO YOUR MARKET FOR
ARI I AND KATIE HAWKINS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA.
EXECUTIVE WRECK AS ARE THE
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR RECREATION
PARTNERSHIP.
WITHOUT I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE BILL WAS MOVED AND SECONDED --
WITNESSES GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM NOT AS AHMED ARE YOU GUYS
OUT THERE PROGRAM MANAGER FOR
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR YEAH I AND QUIRK
WHICH I'M A MEMBER OF IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE.
HERE TO SUPPORT AB.
ELEVEN ELEVEN THE ARC I
COOPERATIVE HAS ONE POINT THREE
MILLION MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TWO
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE.
I'M SORRY I BENEFITS FROM THE
VAST AND IMPRESSIVE OUTDOOR
SPACES THAT MAKE CALIFORNIANS
AND VISITORS WANT TO BE OUTDOORS
I'VE BEEN WITH ARI I SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN DIRECTING A
GUIDING IN OUTFITTING SERVICE
PROVIDING THE PUBLIC WITH
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES THEY MAY NOT
EXPERIENCE BY THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE HOSTED OVER THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS.
IN OUR CYCLING CAMPING PADDLING
CLIMBING AND CAMPING PROGRAMS IN
IN STORE EVENTS AND CLASSES IN
THE FIELD.
COMPANIES LIKE OURS AND HUNDREDS
OF OTHER RECREATIONAL INDUSTRY
PARTNERS ARE ENABLING
CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
TRANSFORMATIVE EXPERIENCES IN
THE OUTDOORS.
THE CHANGING PERFECT PREFERENCES
AND DEMANDS OF OUR CONSUMERS THE
CREATION OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
PRODUCTS AND PATHWAYS TO
RECREATE IS RAPIDLY DISRUPTING
OUR INDUSTRY.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN CREATES A NEW
OFFICE OF OUTDOOR RECREATION
THAT WILL BE A FOCAL POINT FOR
THE OUTDOOR RECREATION INDUSTRY
IN MEETING THOSE CHALLENGES.
IT AFFIRMS THE INCREDIBLE
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE THE OUTDOOR
RECREATION ECONOMY IS TO
CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO CREATES A VISIBLE
PLATFORM TO EMPLOY STRATEGIES TO
BETTER POSITION CALIFORNIA TO
OUTDOOR RECREATION COMPANIES AND
BRANDS THAT WANT TO EXPAND OR
RELOCATE TO CALIFORNIA THE
OFFICE WOULD BUILD COLLABORATION
BETWEEN OUTDOOR GEAR AND APPAREL
MANY FACTORS STATE AGENCIES
GUIDING AND OUTFITTING SERVICES.
WE INTERESTING CONSERVANCY'S
NONPROFITS TO HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY YOUTH IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR ACCESS THE
OUTDOORS IN AN EQUITABLE WAY.
IN OFFICE OF OUTDOOR RECREATION
IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE A GREAT
RESOURCE FOR INDUSTRY AND A WAY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO MAINTAIN AND
GROW ITS OWN COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES.
IN HELPING DEVELOP RECRUIT AND
GROW NEW OUTDOOR RECREATION
LEADERS AND COMPANIES IN THE
STATE I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE FOR A.
B..
ELEVEN ELEVEN GREAT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR -- MY
NAME'S KATIE HAWKINS AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR RECREATION
PARTNERSHIP.
AND I'M HERE TO EXPRESS HER
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN ELEVEN
OUR MISSION IS TO ESTABLISH
EMPOWER VOICE FOR THE ACTIVE
RECREATION INDUSTRY TO TREAT
POLICY DIRECT INVESTMENT AND
ENGAGE A BROADER COMMUNITY OF
OUTDOOR PARTICIPANTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OUTDOOR RECREATION COMPANIES
THAT ARE BASED IN AN OPERATING
CALIFORNIA BENEFIT FROM THE BASS
AND PRESS THE PUBLIC LANDS
NATURAL RESOURCES AND OUTDOOR
SPACES THAT MAKE CALIFORNIANS
WANT TO BE OUTDOORS.
ALL OF US IN THAT -- RECREATION
INDUSTRY PROVIDE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
THE NEW OFFICE ABOUT FOR
RECREATION WOULD SERVE AS A
CENTRAL POINT TO HELP CONNECT
THOSE OF US IN DIFFERENT
INDUSTRY SEGMENTS.
WITH EACH OTHER TO SHARE WHAT
WORKS AND I FEEL AND LOOK FOR
WAYS TO IMPROVE AND GROW OUR
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE.
IT WILL BRING A SHARPER FOCUS
TWO EGGS USING AN EXISTING STATE
TOOLS INCENTIVES AND POLICIES TO
HELP COMPANIES AND BRANDS WITH
MARKET EXPANSION.
EMPLOYMENT GROWTH BEST BUSINESS
PRACTICES AND MARK.
AND IT WOULD BE IT WOULD HELP
BRING A BIGGER SPOTLIGHT TO THE
ISSUES THAT ALL OF US IN THE
INDUSTRY NEED TO BE PAINTED T.
TENSION TO THINGS LIKE
TECHNOLOGY TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
THE OUTDOORS.
BOUNCING RESPONSIBLE RECREATION
WITH STORED SHIPPED.
AND CULTIVATING AWARENESS AND A
LOVE ABOUT DOORS IN OUR YOUTH
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND NON
TRADITIONAL OUTDOOR ENTHUSIASTS.
CREATING AN NEW OFFICE ABOUT A
RECREATION CENTER POSITIVE
SIGNAL TO THE INDUSTRY.
TECH OUTDOOR ENTHUSIASTS AND TO
OTHER STATES IT SHOWS THAT
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES THE
HUNDREDS OF BRANDS RETAILERS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATIONS RECREATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND OTHER INDUSTRY PARTNERS IN
THE STATE ARE A CRITIC CRITICAL
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
IT SHOWS THAT THE STATE VALUES
THE INVESTMENTS THOSE PARTNERS
HAVE MADE INCREASING WORLD LASS
RECREATIONAL PRODUCTS SERVICES
AND EXPERIENCES.
AND THE STATE WILL HELP
ENCOURAGE FUTURE INVESTMENTS.
AND IT SHOWS THAT THE LARGEST
STATE IN THE NATION WITH THE
LARGEST OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY IS READY TO WORK WITH
THE INDUSTRY TO PROMOTE ECONOMIC
HEALTH.
AND EDUCATIONAL AND SOCIAL
BENEFITS BALLOT WELL SUPPORTED
OUTDOOR RECREATION ECONOMIES
BRING TO CALIFORNIA FOR THIS
REASON I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE FOR
EASY.
ELEVEN ELEVEN THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER DOWN FOR ACCOUNT
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE MISTREATMENT EFFORTS
OF PARTICULARLY IN ACKNOWLEDGING
THE ROLE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN
THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TRACY VERNA TOWARDS
ON BEHALF OF THE OUTDOOR
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT THE
CALIFORNIA PARK RECREATION
SOCIETY SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE.
POSITIVE A PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICT WATERSHED CONSERVATION
AUTHORITY IN CINEMA COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MARK SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S LISA
MENACE CONFERENCE THE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON ARMY OFFICER CALL
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MAKE RAN COUNTY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA OUTDOORS IS A STATE
WIDE -- PROFESSIONAL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU -- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE I WILL BRING
IT BACK IN ITS AS ALWAYS NICE
WHEN I CAN SUPPORT ONE OF YOUR
BILL SO.
REMEMBER FRIEDMAN I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD BILL -- SUPPORT IT
LAST YEAR AS WELL -- YOU KNOW OF
THE OF WE HAVE A BEAUTIFUL STATE
AND SO MANY ASPECTS OF IT AND WE
NEED TO GET. ONE OF PROMOTE
THOSE LOCATIONS GET MORE PEOPLE
OUT RECREATION.
APPRECIATE IN OUR RURAL AND
SCENIC PARTS OF THE STATE.
THAT I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
JUST STILL HAVEN'T HAD
OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE AN AND SO I
THINK CREATING THIS.
THIS OFFICE WILL DO A LOT.
TO TO HELP FOR THAT AND FOR ALL
THE REASONS IT WAS STATED BEFORE
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE YES DOCTOR CHOI.
I EVEN THOUGHT THE CONCEPT IS SO
GREAT AND OF PROMOTING OUR
OUTDOOR ACTIVITIES ABOUT -- I'D
JUST OWN WONDER.
IF WE HAVE TO TELL PEOPLE TO GO
OUT AND OF PARTICIPATE IN THESE.
OUTDOOR RECREATION IN ALL WE
ALREADY -- MOM A WHILE AGO VOTED
ON THE PROVIDING -- OUTDOOR
TRANSPORTATION IN A SERVICES OF
FOR DISADVANTAGED THE
COMMUNITIES ETCETERA SO THIS IS
SAID TO ME I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
THIS ORDER REQUIRE EDITION ARE.
A MONEY CREATING AND EITHER A
BUREAUCRACY.
I MEAN DO WE HAVE TO TELL PEOPLE
TO WHAT THEN ENJOY E. ELLO
THROUGH THIS OFFICE.
PEOPLE ALREADY KNOW IF THEY
CHOOSE TO GO OUT AND ENJOY.
AND THE WHOLE -- DISORDER Là
TURNED OUT TO BE IN ALL COST
EFFECTIVE -- AND JUST OF
BLOATING DOUBLE MONTH EXPANSION
INTO WE AGREED TO THAT ASPECT.
IS THAT A QUESTION YEAH NO I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS --
LOADING GOVERNMENT -- AGENCY I
THINK THAT THIS WOULD BE I I
BELIEVE THAT INVESTING MONEY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS MONEY
WELL SPENT.
AND THERE'S A LACK OF
COORDINATION RIGHT NOW BETWEEN A
LOT OF THESE INDUSTRIES AND ALSO
WITH OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES.
AND HAVING THEM ALL AT ONE TABLE
A WAY THAT THEY CAN PRIORITIZE
AND MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
MONEY IS SPENT IS BEING SPENT.
IN -- AREAS THAT THEY ALL AGREE
SHOULD BE PRIORITY AREAS AND
REALLY FOCUSING OUR EFFORTS --
IS IMPORTANT WE DO THIS WITH
MANY AREAS WE DO THIS WITH -- UP
WITH ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BUT WE DON'T AREN'T DOING IT
WITH THIS MAJOR INDUSTRY
STATEWIDE.
SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
DIVERTING SOME YOU KNOW SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY HERE WOULD PAY
DIVIDENDS BACK AS WE BETTER
COORDINATE FOCUS OUR PRIORITIES
AND REALLY GET THE WORD OUT
ABOUT MANY OF THE AREAS OF THE
STATE IS MISTER GALLAGHER SAID.
REALLY HAVE BEEN IGNORED YEAH WE
DON'T NEED TO SPEND A LOT OF
MONEY TO TELL PEOPLE ABOUT THE
SANTA MONICA BEACH PERHAPS BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF PARTS OF I'M
SURE MR GALLAGHER'S DISTRICT.
THAT MY CONSTITUENTS DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT SO GETTING THE
WORD OUT AND AND YOU KNOW COULD
REALLY HELP A LOT OF THOSE --
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT THAT ARE
ARE LESS WELL KNOWN.
ANOTHER AREA THAT I'M ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT THE ONCE
WE CREATE THE SUCH OF
BUREAUCRACY -- THIS OFFICE MAY --
EXERCISE SO ON TO POWER.
AND THE LIMIT THE LAND USE.
OF OVERALL.
I EVEN LIMITING -- THE KARENNA
BUSINESS THE INDUSTRY PRACTICES
SO.
SO UP IN A FOR THE REGULATIONS.
RATHER THAN -- PROMOTING.
AND A LITTLE BIT THE LEGISLATION
IS AGENT OKAY CERTAINLY WOULD
NOT HAVE ANY OUR REGULATORY
AUTHORITY BUT ALL THAT MONEY.
THANK YOU TRACY RIGHT ATORES ON
BEHALF THE OUTER INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AS INSTRUMENTS SAID
THERE ARE ELEVEN I ACTUALLY LAST
WEEK NEW MEXICO PASSED TO DO
OFFICE ABOUT THE REPARATIONS
THERE ARE TWELVE OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE OFFICES LIKE THIS.
NONE OF THEM HAVE LAND
MANAGEMENT RESPONSIBILITIES IN
THE WAY THAT OUR CURRENCY STATE
PARKS DEPARTMENT OR FISH AND
WILDLIFE FRIEDMAN CONSERVANCY'S
WOULD HAVE.
THESE ARE ALL AS MISS FRIEDMAN
MENTIONED REALLY COORDINATING
AND FACILITATING OFFICES AND IN
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT HAPPEN IN
PRIOR YEARS OF THIS OFFICE THAT
THE VISION WAS REALLY ABOUT A
TWO PERSON OFFICE.
THAT IS REALLY LOOKING AS MISS
BERMAN SAID ACROSS GOVERNMENT
AND THAT INCLUDES FEDERAL
AGENCIES LOCAL STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES THAT OUR LAND
MANAGERS BUT ALSO AS THE
WITNESSES SAID.
LOOKING AT THE BUSINESSES
COMPANIES BRANDS AND RECREATION
PROVIDERS AND BRINGING THEM ALL
TO THE TABLE BUT THEY THAT THIS
OFFICE IS NOT INTENDED. TO
EITHER RUN PROGRAMS IN PARKS OR
TO MANAGE LANDS.
OKAY THANKS A NUMBER DOLLY.
THE RINGS BEFORE I JUST LIKE.
TO SAY THAT TOM.
I'M I'M HUGE SUPPORTER ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL -- I
REPRESENT TO ALONG WITH THE SAME
MEMBER GALLAGHER VAST.
LANDSCAPES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE.
UNDER UTILIZED AND I BELIEVE
THIS -- AND I'M NOT I'M ONE
THAT'S CRITICAL ALSO OF GETTING
TOO MUCH GOVERNMENT BUT AS I
LOOKED AROUND THE ROOM AND I SEE
ALL THE FAIR POSTERS IN THIS
ROOM RIGHT.
AND WE MADE AN ARGUMENT A COUPLE
YEARS AGO ABOUT HOW MUCH THE
FAIRS ACTUALLY PRODUCE.
VERSES THE MOUNT WE PUT IN AND
THE TAX BASE THAT COMES BACK TO
OUR COMMUNITIES THE T. O. T.
THAT'LL COME BACK FROM THIS -- I
THINK WE'LL OVERWHELMINGLY.
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
COMING IN FROM PEOPLE FROM OUT
OF STATE -- AND ACROSS THE WORLD
ACTUALLY -- TO COME TO OUR STATE
AND I THINK THIS IS A
APPROPRIATELY -- DID.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT WILL
ACTUALLY INCREASE REVENUES FOR
CALIFORNIA SO I THE WHOLE HARLEY
SUPPORTERS BUT THESE LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
CENA FOR THE COMMON CENTER
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
TO BEN CLEAR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER LET ME JUST MAKE SURE
WE DID GET A MOTION TO SAY I
THINK IT WAS CRISTINA YEAH AND
AND STE YEAH.
THE MOTION A SECOND GO HEAD.
EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER HI
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING CHIU.
CHIU I DELHI.
DELHI I FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
KALRA I LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
LIKE A RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
WOOD I HI.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I THAT IS. THIRTEEN WILL
THE FIA.
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ONE
MEMBER TO ACTUALLY.
OKAY LET'S EVERYONE ALL RIGHT
WILL THIS NEW BILL WILL MOVE TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
MR SOME.
A. B..
FOR EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THIS IS THAT SENSUALLY AT
AT TECHNICAL FIX. TO CLARIFY
THAT.
SO WHEN WE HAVE CERTAIN PRE
APPROVED.
FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS THE STATE
TYPICALLY PICKS UP 50% OF THE
NON FEDERAL SHARE WHAT WE'RE
ASKING IS TO EXTEND THE PARTS
WHERE THIS STATE CAN'T PICK UP
70%.
OF THE FEDERAL OF THE NON
FEDERAL SHARE A SIMILAR PROJECT
MEET CERTAIN CRITERIA AND IN
THIS BILL WERE CLARIFYING THAT
RECREATIONAL PROJECTS ARE ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT THE STATE.
COULD INCREASE ITS PERCENTAGE.
OF THE NON FEDERAL SHARE AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I OBJECT LOCAL HERE WE
HAVE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY FLOOD
CONTROL DISTRICT WHICH IS
WORKING ON SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS.
AND WE'RE HOPING TO BE ABLE TO
CLARIFY THIS SO THAT WE CAN GET
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF STATE
SHARE.
IN A PROJECT ON THE POWER OF
RIVER.
MOTION AND SECOND SQUAD MISTER
CHAIRMAN GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
JACK WALK AWAY AS INDICATED BY
MISTER STONE SIMPLY WANT TO SAY
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF DISCUSSION
TODAY ABOUT THE VALUE OF
RECREATION IN.
A HOST OF THINGS NOW WE PROPERLY
AND EFFICIENTLY EXPEND PROP ONE
OF PROP SIXTY EIGHT MONIES.
GIVEN WHAT THE NGOS IN THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES ROOMS
SPENDING ON RECREATION AND AND
FLOOD CONTROL WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE ARE PROBABLY
MARRIED AND PROPERLY USE THE
MONEY THAT THE THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA VOTED.
FOR THANK YOU THANK YOU --
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF BILL.
IN WHICH IS BEGIN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PLEASE DON CLARIFY REAL QUICK SO
THESE ARE AREAS WHERE -- LIKE
RIGHT HERE SACRAMENTO OR THE
THEY HAVE RECREATIONAL AREAS BUT
THEY OPEN THE FLOODGATES AND USE
THAT FOR A RELIEF FOR FLOOD
TIMES AND THEN IT REVERTED BACK
TO RECREATION AFTER THAT SO IS
IT BENEFICIAL USE. FORTY EXACTLY
SO FOR EXAMPLE DISCOVERY PARK
HERE HAS RECREATION VENUES IN
ADS WHEN IT IS NOT CURRENTLY IN
FLOOD SO THESE ARE AREAS THAT
HELP US MANAGE THE FLOOD WHEN
THEY'RE NOT IN FLOOD WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE THEY ARE
AVAILABLE FOR RECREATIONAL
FACILITIES.
THIS IS CHANGE THE DEFINITION SO
THAT WE CAN INCREASE THE STATE'S
PORTION OF THE NON FEDERAL SHARE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THESE
PROJECTS TO HAPPEN HAD HAPPENED
AN APPROPRIATE WAY.
CNN WE DO HAVE A MOTION SECOND
CHECK CLOTHES I ASK HERE EITHER
THANK YOU ROLE COMPANIES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT WATER GARCIA GARCIA I
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW ON AYE CHOI HI CHOI AYE
CHU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA I
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE CHOLERA BUT I LEVINE.
THE GREEN EYED BLANCA RUBIO.
BLANCA RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
WOULD I IT'S TAKING.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ANOTHER MEMBER -- TO ADD ON WE
HAVE UP I DON'T FIVE A. B..
FOUR FIFTY FOUR BY MISTER KALRA
[inaudible]
RIGHT
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS --
I'M HAPPY -- TO TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR FIVE FOUR WHICH JUROR WHICH
ADDRESS THE DANGEROUS LOOPHOLE
AND CALIFORNIA'S WILDLIFE
PROTECTION LAW.
AS YOU SEE WITH OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE CLEAN WATER CLEAN AIR
ENDANGERED SPECIES OFFSHORE OIL
DRILLING.
ATTEMPTS TO DISMANTLE FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AND STANDARDS
HAS PUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
CHALLENGING POSITION OF BEING TO
SECURE PROTECTION FOR NATURAL
TREASURES.
MIGRATORY BIRDS HAVE BEEN
RECOGNIZING CALIFORNIA LAW AND
IN OUR COURTS AS AN IMPORTANT
NATURAL RESOURCE WITH INTRINSIC
VALUE FOR THE STATE'S NATURAL
HISTORY THAT ALSO PROVIDES.
SIGNIFICANT ECOLOGICAL ECONOMIC
AND RECREATIONAL BENEFITS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO HUMAN
ACTIVITIES MANY MIGRATORY BIRD
POPULATIONS OF DECLINE
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THE HISTORIC
NUMBERS IN THE STATE MUST BE
ABLE TO RESPONSIBLY MANAGE AND
PROTECT THEM TO ENSURE THEIR
NUMBERS ARE NOT NEEDLESSLY
DECLINED FURTHER.
AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN PATIENT GO
KICK GAME CODE SECTION THREE
FIVE ONE THREE PROHIBITS THE
KILLING OF MIGRATORY BIRDS
UNLESS ALLOWED BY THE RULES OR
REGULATIONS ISSUED FROM THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
PURSUANT TO THE FEDERAL
MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT WITH
THE MBTA.
THE MBTA IS ONE OF THE NATION'S
OLDEST ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AND
FOR DECADES IT HAS BEEN
ADMINISTERED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROHIBIT SO CALLED
INCIDENTAL TAKE OR THE
UNINTENTIONAL BUT PERCEIVABLE
KILLING OF MIGRATORY BIRDS.
DURING OTHERWISE LEGAL
ACTIVITIES.
THE MBTA IS CREDITED WITH
HELPING CONSERVE.
HUNDREDS OF BIRD SPECIES
INCLUDING SUCH NOTABLE SPECIES
AS THE SAND HILL CRANES.
RED TAILED HAWK AND BURROWING
OWL WHICH ARE NOT PROTECTED BY
OTHER FEDERAL STATUTE.
THE PROVIDES THE BASIS
RECOVERING NATURAL RESOURCE
DAMAGES FROM EVENTS LIKE THE
EXXON VALDEZ OIL SPILL IN ALASKA
AND THE COSCO BUSAN SPILL ON THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY.
IT ALSO INCENTIVIZE INDUSTRIES
WAS ACTIVITIES GOAL BIRDS TO
DEVELOP METHODS TO AVOID AND
MINIMIZE THEIR IMPACTS.
THE BITE THIS DESPITE THE
SUCCESSES OF THE MBTA MOST
MIGRATORY BIRD SPECIES IN
CALIFORNIA IN DECLINE LARGELY
DUE TO A LOT LOSS OF HABITAT AND
DIRECT IMPACTS OF HUMAN ACTIVITY.
THE NORTH AMERICA AT LEAST FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO BIRD SPECIES
MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF BIRDS
THAT OCCUR ON THE CONTINENT ARE
AT HIGH RISK OF EXTINCTION
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT CONSERVATION
ACTION.
HOWEVER DESPITE THESE BOX IN
LATE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS FOR A
LEGAL OPINION THAT REVERSED.
DECADES OF BIPARTISAN GOVERNMENT
POLICY AND PRACTICE OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND FOR SOME OF
THE MBTA.
IN PARTICULAR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAID IT WOULD NO
LONGER CONSIDER THE MBTA TO
PROHIBIT INCIDENTAL TAKE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
INTERPRETATION WOULD MEAN THAT
THERE WOULD BE NO LIABILITY FOR
CALLING BIRDS UNDER THE MBTA
FROM MASSIVE EVENTS LIKE THE
EXXON VALDEZ OR DEEP WATER
HORIZON OIL SPILLS.
IT ALSO OPENS THE DOOR FOR
INDUSTRIES LIKE MINING AND OIL
DRILLING TO KILL MIGRATORY BIRDS
WITHOUT AN ATTEMPT TO AVOID A
MEDICAID.
SUCH IMPACTS.
AS CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION GROWS
INDUSTRIES CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THE CLIMATE CHANGES AND
RESOURCES BECOME SCARCER.
AS FEDERAL ROLL BACK TO THE MBTA
IT CREATED A VACUUM AND WILDLIFE
PROTECTION CERTAINTY IS NEEDED
FOR BOTH CONSERVATION EFFORTS
AND INDUSTRY. TO ENSURE THAT
BIRDS AND OTHER NATURAL
RESOURCES ARE PROTECTED.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IT'S REAL LEGAL ADVISORY LAST
NOVEMBER IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
REAFFIRMING CALIFORNIA STATE LAW
PROTECTION FOR BIRDS AS STATING
THAT STATE LAW PROHIBITS
INCIDENTAL TAKE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIVE FOUR
SIMPLY MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
RETAINS AUTHORITY TO MAKE ITS
OWN RULES REGARDING MIGRATORY
BIRD PROTECTIONS.
IT WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA MANAGES
CONSTITUTIONAL PUBLIC TRUST IS
POSSIBILITY TO PROTECT BIRDS AND
HABITAT.
AND WILL NOT UNNECESSARILY
DEFERRED THEM TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
BEFORE I CONCLUDE MY REMARKS I
FEEL THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION FROM GROUPS
REPRESENTING AGRICULTURE TIMBER
HARVEST WIND AND SOLAR PRODUCERS.
THESE ARE INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE
THRIVED FOR DECADES UNDER THE
LONGSTANDING INTERPRETATION THAT
THE MBTA PROHIBITS AND THEN I'LL
TAKE. TO MY KNOWLEDGE NONE OF
BEEN PROSECUTED FOR INCIDENT
INCIDENTAL TAKE UNDER STATE OR
FEDERAL LAW.
IT IS SIMPLY NOT CREDIBLE FOR
OPPOSITION TO CLAIM THAT
MAINTAINING THE STATUS QUO FOR
BIRD PROTECTIONS IN THE STATE.
AS IT HAS BEEN FOR AT LEAST FOUR
DECADES WILL HARM THEIR
INDUSTRIES PREVENT CALIFORNIA
FROM REACHING IMPORTANT ECONOMIC
A RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS.
IT WASN'T LONG AGO THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CYNICALLY ATTACK
THE WIND ENERGY PRODUCERS BIRD
KILLERS AT THAT AN ENERGY PLAN
THE CALIFORNIA DESERT MADE NEWS
ON IT WAS IGNITING BIRDS.
ON FIRE IN MIDAIR IN THESE CASES
AND MANY OTHERS THESE INDUSTRIES
AND THEIR DEFENDERS NOTED THAT
GREAT EFFORTS.
OF THE GREAT APRS THEY WERE
MAKING TO REDUCE AND MITIGATE
ANY ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS FROM THE
RAPID EXPANSION THERE
INCENTIVIZE TO DO SO BY THE
PROTECTIONS FOR MIGRATORY BIRDS.
THAT PREVENT INCIDENTAL TAKE AND
THEIR ACTIONS AS AN OPERATIONS
WERE BUBBLE REVERB -- COMPLIANCE
WITH THE MBTA RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
YET NOW THESE GROUPS JOIN WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND APPLIED AS
ADMINISTRATION WERE ROLLING BACK
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS DONE
BETTER AND WE SHOULD NOT LET
THESE INDUSTRIES UNDERMINE OUR
STATE'S AUTHORITY RESPONSIBILITY
PROTECT MIGRATORY BIRDS
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE'RE JUST
GOING BACK TO THE WAY THAT WE'VE
BEEN OPERATING. FOR DECADES UP
UNTIL LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIVE FOUR I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE -- AND AT THIS TIME
BUT ASK MIKE LINES MODEL ON
CALIFORNIA PERS. TO MAKE MY SAYS
OF EXCELLENCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MIKE LINES
ON THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY
FOR AUTO IN CALIFORNIA I WANT TO
FIRST THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS BILL AND
STANDING UP FOR MIGRATORY BIRDS.
AND ECHO HIS COMMENTS AROUND THE
IMPORTANCE OF BASE TO THE STATE
TO PROVIDE BILLIONS IN INCOME
AND ECOLOGICAL ECOLOGICAL VALUE
IN RECREATIONAL VALUE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THEIR NUMBERS
HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT DECLINE
FOR DECADES.
ON ONE SUPPORTS A BEFORE FIVE
FOUR BECAUSE IT'S NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
CONTINUE TO PROTECT BIRDS AS
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE STATE. FOR
MANY MANY DECADES WITHOUT BEING
UNDERMINED BY THE EROSION OF
FEDERAL BIRD PROTECTIONS BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IF THE ADMINISTRATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL OUR
SUCCESSFUL INDUSTRY WILL BE
ALLOWED TO KILL MIGRATORY BIRDS
WITH IMPUNITY EVEN EVENTS AS
MENTIONED LIKE MAJOR OIL SPILLS
OVER INDUSTRY IS GROSSLY
NEGLIGENT.
IN FAILING TO ADDRESS SOURCES OF
KNOWN -- MORTALITY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MENTIONED THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT ATTORNEY GENERAL --
LEGAL ADVISORY.
I'M SORRY. 200-020-0018.
LEGAL ADVISORY FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND I WANT TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THE MAJOR
POINTS. ONE IT MADE CLEAR THAT
WITHIN THE STATE'S CONSTITUTION
AND THE PUBLIC TRUST DOCTRINE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
CHARGED WITH OWNERSHIP AND
MANAGING THE BIRDS FOR THE
PUBLIC TRUST.
IT ALSO MADE CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS ALWAYS
APPLIED INCIDENTAL TAKE WITHIN
THE FISHING GAME CODE.
AGAIN THIS IS BEEN THE WAY IT
HAS BEEN FOR YEARS I KNOW THAT
NONE OF THE OPPOSITION LETTERS.
EVEN REFER TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL LEGAL ADVISORY.
BOARD ADDRESS ANY OF THE COURT
CASES THAT ARE CITED THEREIN.
AB FOUR FIVE FOUR IS INTENDED TO
FIX A PROBLEM IN THE FISHING
GAME CODE SECTION THIRTY FIVE
THIRTEEN WHICH ALLOWS TAKE WITH
THE RULES AND REGULATIONS ARE
PROMULGATED FROM DEPARTMENT
INTERIOR. THIRTY FIVE THIRTEEN
WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN AT A TIME WHEN IT WAS WELL
UNDERSTOOD BY BOTH PARTIES.
THAT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE
MBTA APPLIED INSTILL TAKE IT WAS
THERE TO SWEEP IN SOME
EXEMPTIONS OF THE PART OF IN
CHERRY HEARD IT HAD ISSUED.
AROUND -- SO TAKE THAT MAY OCCUR
FOR SCIENTIFIC A VETERINARY
PURPOSES OR PROTECT PROPS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH.
THEY WERE VERY NARROW EXEMPTIONS
AT THIRTY FIVE THIRTEEN WAS
TRYING TO SWEEP INTO STATE LAW.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTEEN WAS NEVER
INTENDED TO PROVIDE A BROAD
EXEMPTION INCIDENTAL TAKE WHICH
IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN IF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION GOES FORWARD AS
IT SAYS IT.
WILL. TO IMPLEMENT A NEW
REGULATION UNDER THE MBTA THAT
ALLOWS INCIDENTAL TAKE.
THE LAST POINT ON THAT IS --
SEVERAL PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME CODE TO
PROHIBIT THE TAKE OF NATIVE
BIRDS MIGRATORY BIRDS.
BUT SAY THAT IS NOT IT IS
ALLOWED IF IT IS OTHERWISE
PROVIDED IN THE CODE.
SO THE LOOPHOLE IN THIRTY FIVE
THIRTEEN TO CREATE PROBLEMS AND
THIRTY FIVE OR THREE THIRTY FIVE
A THREE POINT FIVE AND THIRTY
EIGHT HUNDRED WHICH ALL PROVIDE
PREVENT PROTECTIONS.
THE BILL [inaudible]
I GOT [inaudible]
OR YOU KNOW WHAT IS THAT SOME OF
FINISHED [inaudible]
CHECK THEM.
SO THE LOT AT LAST REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT AS WITH A
CALIFORNIA WILL SELF DETERMINE
IN MAKE UP ITS OWN MIND BUT HOW
WILL MANAGE MIGRATORY BIRDS
WITHIN ITS BORDERS.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GET OUT A GOOD MORNING CAM
DELFINO WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE -- I'M ALL MAKE THIS
PRETTY BRIEF BECAUSE I THINK
THAT -- AND THE ISSUES OF
ALREADY BEEN COVERED WHAT I'LL
JUST SAY IS THAT.
THE OPPOSITION WILL GET UP HERE
TODAY AND THEY'LL TALK ABOUT ALL
OF THE CONCERNS OVER THE CHANGES
BEING TO LOBBYING PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL BUT I THINK THAT THE
THE POINT IS BEEN WELL MADE THAT
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT THE BILL
IS HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF A
UNILATERAL.
CHANGE THAT WAS MADE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR SOLICITOR
WHO OUT OF THE BLUE ISSUED AN
OPINION REVERSING DECADES OF LAW.
THAT SAID THAT THAT THE
MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT A LOT
OF DID NOT ALLOW INCIDENTAL TAKE
OF MIGRATORY BIRDS.
SO WITH THIS CHANGE IT'S
ACTUALLY CREATED A HUGE AMOUNT
OF UNCERTAINTY WITH IN
CALIFORNIA LAW AND ALL THIS BILL
DOES IS TRY TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY
AGAIN.
WHICH IS GO BACK TO THE WAY
THINGS WERE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN BEFORE THIS UNILATERAL
CHANGE AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL.
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE IT
WILL NOT CREATE UNCERTAINTY IN
FACT WILL CREATE MORE CERTAINTY
AND IS ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S MIGRATORY
BIRDS AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE.
HE SAID ELEVEN SALAS WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR HIS CONTINUED WORK ON THIS
ISSUE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ULTRA LIBERAL NON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA RELIEF IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THREE SEPARATE
VERGE ON BEHALF OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISERS THE
FIVE JARS INSTITUTE PLASTIC
POLLUTION COALITION AND THE
CENTER FOR OCEANIC AWARENESS
RESEARCH AND EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT.
POINT OUT THAT MEET ON ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
PROTECTION AT WORK IN THE MONO
LAKE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE MINUTES ONLY HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND THANK THE
AUTHOR VERY MUCH FOR THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON ON BEHALF
HYSTERICAL CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRIAN A WIKI THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND IF I MAY TWO VERY
BRIEF POINTS THAT WERE NOT MET
IN THE IN THE PREVIOUS.
TESTIMONY THE WIND ENERGY
GUIDELINES AND OTHER GUIDANCE
DECIDED IN THE CAL WE OPPOSITION
LETTER WERE ONLY DEVELOP THOSE
GOT ANSWERED ABOUT BECAUSE THE
FEDS AND WHEN COMPANIES
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE MBTA
PROTECTED AGAINST INCIDENTAL
TAKE YOU.
SYKORA VERY BRIEFLY ONE SENTENCE
HERE SYKORA DOES NOT PROVIDE
PROTECTION FOR MIGRATORY BIRDS
WHEN IT FOCUSES ON SPECIAL
STATUS SPECIES THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
PAUL DURRENBERGER SUMMER WITH
DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE IN THE
BROOKLYN IN RIGHT CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STACEY PLACATE ISN'T SAN DIEGO I
WHEN YOU BERMAN FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA ANONYMOUS FOR THE
VOICELESS I SUPPORT?
LINDA MIDDLE FOR SACRAMENTO
VEGAN SOCIETY WITH FOUR THOUSAND
MEMBERS DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE
AND PIZZA THANK YOU.
IN SUPPORT.
GIL AND HAZEL OFFERS SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MERRIAM KAMALI BELMONT
AMANDA OXFORD WALNUT CREEK
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
DILLON HERMAN BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA A SUPPORT.
WALLACE SENATORIAL FAIRFIELD
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT.
ALEX ON TORIO FOR FEEL IN
SUPPORT.
IN TURN YOU MORE SAN MATTEO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LIVE FUNDING WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I SUPPORT.
I AM AN AVON FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA AND DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE I SUPPORT.
RAZA BETTERS QAEDA FROM SAN
CARLOS CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
J. FITZ GERALD FROM STANISLAUS
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SAY THAT IS VERY FROM SAN JOSE
SUPPORT.
MARYAM LAZAROV FROM SAN JOSE I
REPRESENT.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY ACTIVISTS FOR
ANIMALS STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MIKE SAGE SANTA CLARA SUPPORT.
FLOOD DOORS WITH IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS REPRESENTING OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC MANY OF THEM IN
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
MATTHEW HAMIDI WITHIN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS FROM ALBANY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL GOLDBERG BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA HI REPRESENT
COMPASSIONATE BAY AND I SUPPORT.
I'M MORE CAN WE CALIFORNIA WATER
PHONE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S ANASTASIA MAIL I'M
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS.
I'M LESLEY GOLDBERG FROM EL
SERENO CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT
COMPASSIONATE BAY.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SANDY MAIL BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
FROM DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BRIANNA MARTELLO SO
FROM SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA -- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M JIM GARDNER MARCELLO'S
OFFENSE SAN DIEGO OF DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE I SUPPORT IT'S
WHAT MERIT THOMAS HERNANDEZ THE
CREATOR OF THE ENDS OF YUBA CITY.
AND I SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS HANNAH CALLED PAPER
I'M FROM ONE THE CALIFORNIA I'M
WITH TRACKS ACTION EVERYWHERE.
AND NON WAS FOR THE VOICELESS
NAY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S DAN SHOW IN FROM OUT
TO CALIFORNIA -- WITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE X. SEE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
LOUIS BERNIE A WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE BERKELEY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NGUYEN CHUNG FROM DIXIE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THAT IT BUT THERE IS
A CAMPUS WIDE AS I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS MATTHEW THEM SCANNED
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
JOHN FROM MEYER FROM BERKELEY
WITH DIRECT ACTION EVERYWHERE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SONJI THIS MONDAY FROM DALY CITY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION OF
RIVERA AND I SUPPORT THIS WEB.
STEPANEK OF RACQUETS FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA EMMA
ORGANIZER WITH OUR DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ALICIA SENATORIAL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT
ACTION EVERYWHERE AND THE SAVE
MOVEMENT AND I SUPPORT THIS BOOK.
I'M JACKIE LAWRENCE FROM
BERKELEY AND WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THOMAS CHIANG FROM TOWN SAM'S A
SCHOOL CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MEGAN STEIN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
I'M WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS AMIR TENER I'M FROM
SAN JOSE WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CASSIE KING FROM BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA WITH DIRECT ACTION
EVERYWHERE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GIVING UP TOMORROW FROM.
SACRAMENTO ANONYMOUS VOICES.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MATTHEW MCKENNA FROM OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU I I SEE ANY
YEP MEMBERS OF DIRECT ACTION
FROM CALEXICO MEN AND A BABY.
THIS.
COME UP NEXT TIME.
YOU GET THE MORE DIVERSE
REPRESENTATION THERE.
WILL LAST THE THOSE WHO ARE
GOING TO BE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD
. FOR SINGLE PICKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I THINK THAT THERE'S A
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT OVER
WHAT STATE AND FEDERAL LAW ARE
AT VARIOUS POINTS IN TIME.
AND I THINK THAT BOTH SIDES ON
THIS ISSUE THINK THAT THEY'RE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY -- I
THINK THE AUDUBON HAS EXPRESSED
THAT THE MOST THE RECENT
DECISION AT THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL
CONTRADICTS DECADES OF FEDERAL
POLICY BECAUSE IT REFERS
REVERSED A LONGSTANDING
INTERPRETATION OF THE MBTA.
HOWEVER -- THIS INTERPRETATION
WAS ONLY FORMALIZED BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THE YEAR BEFORE
THE TRUMP -- DECISION CAME OUT.
I BELIEVE THAT OUR INDUSTRIES
BELIEVE THAT.
WE ALSO STAND ON GOOD FOOTING
BECAUSE IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE US
COURT OF APPEALS IN THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT HELD.
THAT THE MBTA PROTECTION
PROVISION DOES NOT INCLUDE THAT
IN UNINTENTIONAL TAKE.
SORRY THE UNINTENTIONAL TAKE A
MIGRATORY BIRDS AND PRIOR TO THE
SIT GO DECISION THE US COURT OF
APPEALS FOR THE EIGHTH CIRCUIT.
AND THE US COURT OF APPEALS FOR
THE NINTH CIRCUIT SIMILARLY HELD
THAT THE MBTA APPLIED ONLY TO
THE INTENTIONAL TAKE OR CAPTURE
MIGRATORY BIRDS.
SUCH AS HUNTING OR TRAPPING.
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
MBTA WAS INTERPRETED APPLY ONLY
TO AFFIRMATIVE ACTIONS THAT HAVE
AS THEIR PURPOSE THE TAKE OR
KILLING A MIGRATORY BIRDS.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
INTERPRETATION IS AS BAD AS THE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT THAT WITH THE
FAQS THAT SUBSEQUENTLY FOLLOWED
AS A RESULT OF THAT -- AND IN
THAT GUIDANCE DOCUMENT I THINK
THERE WAS A SHE WON A PORTION
THAT SAID IS REMOVING A
STRUCTURE FOR EXAMPLE A
DILAPIDATED BARN KNOWN.
WITH NO NESTING.
FOR SORRY NO NESTING OWLS IN THE
BARN WHICH WILL DIE IS THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE OF THE BURN A
VIOLATION MBTA ANSWERED THIS
WOULD NOT BE A VIOLATION OF THE
MBTA.
REMOVING OR DESTROYING THE
STRUCTURE WOULD RARELY IF EVER
BE THE ACT THAT HAS THE FEELING
I'LL NESTLINGS AS ITS PURPOSE WE
DON'T JUST WE DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT.
FAQ THAT CAME OUT ON THAT AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT MANY
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD STAND HERE
SAYING THAT THEY'VE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY APPROVE.
OF WHAT THE FAQ WAS -- I THINK
THAT THE AUDUBON HAS ALSO
MENTION INCIDENT THAT THEY DON'T
THINK THE MBTA WOULDN'T ALONG
WITH NO LONGER APPLY TO
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
SUCH AS THE DEEPWATER HORIZON
WHERE AN OIL SPILL.
DESTROYED OR INJURED UP TO A
MILLION BIRDS SINCE INTENT WAS
NOT ORIGINALLY TO KILL THE BIRDS --
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
SUPPORT -- IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE MINISTRY
OF ACTION HOWEVER I WILL SAY
THAT IN THE PAST ESPECIALLY LAST
YEAR WITH THE INTRODUCTION --
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN IN ONE
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IT
SAID THAT THE TOP HUMAN RELATED
THREATS TO BIRDS IN THE UNITED
STATES ARE AS FOLLOWS.
CATS WHICH KILL AN ESTIMATED TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION BILLION BIRDS
PER YEAR COLLISIONS WITH
BUILDING GLASS WHICH KILL AN
ESTIMATED THREE HUNDRED AND
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION BIRDS
PER YEAR.
COLLISIONS WITH VEHICLES WHICH
CON ESTIMATED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION BIRDS PER YEAR POISONS
WHICH KILL AN ESTIMATED
SEVENTEEN SHOOT SEVENTY TWO
MILLION PARTS PER YEAR.
COLLISIONS WITH ELECTRICAL LINES
WILL KILL AN ESTIMATED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION BIRDS PER YEAR
COLLISIONS WITH COMMUNICATIONS
TOWERS.
ELECTROCUTION OIL PITS
COLLISIONS WITH WIND TURBINES.
NOR ON THEIR ITS FORESTRY LISTED
WE HAVE SOME OF THE MOST STRICT
FORCE PRACTICE RULES IN IN THE
NATION IF NOT IN THE WORLD.
WE TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN WHAT IT
IS THAT WE DO WE HAVE A GREAT
CONCERN IN THIS BILL THAT --
AGRICULTURE HAS HAD A LONG
STANDING DEFINITION WHICH
PROVIDES FOR THE INCIDENTAL TAKE
FOR ACTS THAT OCCUR ON A FARM OR
RANCH DURING THE COURSE OF
OTHERWISE LAWFUL ROUTINE AND
ONGOING AGRICULTURAL ACTIVITIES.
WE WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
IN ORDER FOR OUR OPPOSITION TO
BE -- RELIEVED AT THIS POINT
THAT FORESTRY BE CONSIDERED AS
PART OF THE ON GOING AND AND
ROUTINE ACTIVITIES OF
AGRICULTURE FOR PURPOSES OF MBTA
ONLY -- AND THAT'S OUR
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING NO -- KRAMER'S THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
I WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THE
SIGNIFICANT HABITAT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE AND
CALIFORNIA'S FORCE PROVIDE TO
BIRDS AND MANY OTHER WILDLIFE
SPECIES.
AND IF IT IF NOT FOR THESE OPEN
SPACES.
WE WOULD HAVE A LOT MORE
DEVELOPMENT AND WE WOULD HAVE A
LOT LESS WILDLIFE HABITAT.
BUT PROVIDING THAT HABITAT
CREATES REGULATORY RISKS AND
UNCERTAINTY FOR THE PRODUCTION
OF FOOD AND MANAGEMENT OF OUR
FORESTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE THAT THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY MAINTAINING THE STATUS
QUO.
IF YOU LOOK AT LINE TWELVE IT
GIVES THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE THE AUTHORITY TO ADOPT
A REGULATION THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH.
OR MORE PROTECTIVE THAN RULES
AND REGULATIONS ADOPTED BY THE
US SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
UNDER THE FEDERAL ACT.
THAT'S WHERE OUR CONCERN LIES.
IS GIVING THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THE AUTHORITY TO GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND.
THE EXISTING AND FORMER
INTERPRETATION OF THE MIGRATORY
BIRD TREATY ACT.
SO WE HAVE TO SPECIFIC CONCERNS
IN THAT AREA.
FIRST THERE ARE LONG STANDING
PROVISIONS UNDER THE FEDERAL ACT
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE WELL
BEFORE THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE TAKE OF CERTAIN MIGRATORY
BIRDS.
THAT DAMAGE CROPS OR PREVENT A
HUMAN HEALTH AND SAFETY RISK.
THIS BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT TO ACCEPT THOSE LONG
STANDING PROVISIONS.
THE OTHER PIECE THAT'S NOT THAT
IS CONCERNING AND MORE
CONCERNING IN FACT IS JUST
GIVING THE DEPARTMENT CARP WASH
AUTHORITY. TO MOVE FORWARD AND
ADOPT REGULATIONS THAT CAN GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND.
WHAT IS IN?
THE CURRENT AND FORMER
INTERPRETATION MIGHT DRAPER
TREATY ACT SO OUR CONCERN IS
THAT.
GIVEN THE RISKS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN HARVESTING CROPS OR
MANAGING OUR FORESTS OR MANAGING
THE LANDS THAT THERE IS
POTENTIAL FOR TAKE AND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MAY NOT ALLOW FOR
THAT WHICH CREATES GREAT
REGULATORY UNCERTAINTY FOR
CONTINUING TO PRODUCE FOOD IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS FOR THAT REASON THAT
WE OPPOSE THE BILL -- I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT WE WORKED ON
CLOSELY WITH THE SPONSORS LAST
YEAR ON AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN AND THEY ACTUALLY DID
ACCEPT.
AMENDMENTS THAT RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGES THAT AGRICULTURE AND
CREATED AN EXEMPTION FOR
AGRICULTURE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
AND PROTECTION FOR FORESTRY AS
WELL -- AND AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU WERE GONNA ASK THOSE
ONE TO STATE YOUR NAME RELATION
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WIND
ENERGY ASSOCIATION VERY BRIEFLY
IF I MAY THE AUTHOR DID NOTE
THAT OUR INDUSTRY.
HAS NOT HISTORICALLY BEEN
PROSECUTED UNDER THE ACT WE
BELIEVE THAT CHANGES UNDER THIS
BILL POTENTIALLY RETROACTIVELY
WE ARE ALREADY SUBJECT TO A
NUMBER OF GUIDELINES BEST
PRACTICE GUIDELINES FEDERALLY AS
WELL AS SEQUEL HERE IN THE STATE.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU NEXT FIRST.
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS DELANEY
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
AND FOR MY COLLEAGUE SHANNON
EDDIE AT THE LARGE SCALE SOLAR
ASSOCIATION.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
VALERIE NEARBY THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION.
MARGOT PARKS MAP OF THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION AND ONE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CONCERN SHARED.
WITH FARM BUREAU ABOUT THE THE
DUPLICATION THINKING.
BRIAN WHITE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FORCES
ASSOCIATION AND THE FORCE ANNALS
OF CALIFORNIA WERE ALSO OPPOSE
WITH THE AFFIRMATION STATED
REASONS WERE CONCERNED THAT THE
BILL COULD ON INTENSELY IMPACT
GOVERNOR.
BROWN'S AND GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
EXECUTIVE ORDERS DEALING WITH
FORCE MANAGEMENT AND THE PACE OF
SKILL TO DEAL CATHOLIC WILDFIRES
THANK.
RIGHT THE NUMBER YOU BACK GOOD.
LUCK TO ADDRESS ANY OF COMES A
BIT MADE THEN WILL BRING AN OPEN
UP FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
THERE'S A LOT TO RESPOND IN FACT
YOUR STAFF DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
AND ACTUALLY -- IF IF MEMBERS OF
THEIR STAFFS HAVE.
HAD A CHANCE TO READ THE REPORT
YOU'LL SEE FOR EXAMPLE A CURRENT
LAW ALREADY ALLOWS THE FISHING
GAME.
BOOK THE COMMISSION TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS THAT CONFORM WITH OR
FURTHER RESTRICT THE RULES
REGULATIONS PRESCRIBED PERCENT
MBTA THIS IS NOT SOMETHING NEW
WITH THIS BILL.
IT'S JUST CODIFYING BUT LAW HAS
BEEN AND HAS EXISTED IN OUR
STATE AGAIN FOR MANY MANY MANY
YEARS -- FURTHER MORE -- THE A A
THE FOR WHAT THIS DOES AND THE
REASON WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT.
IS THAT.
IN PAST YEARS.
WE HAVE BEEN APPROPRIATELY
DEFERRING TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR IN ORDER TO CREATE.
THE OF THE GUIDELINES OR RULES
AS IT APPLIES A MIGRATORY BIRDS
AND WE TALK ABOUT IS AN ALL
TAKES NOT SAYING THAT NO BIRDS
CAN DIE BUT BIRDS DIE ALL THE
TIME AS YOU CAN SEE.
DUE TO LEGAL.
BUSINESS OPERATIONS IT'S JUST
MAKING SURE THAT THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE PUT IN PLACE
MEDICATION IS WHAT IS PUT IN
PLACE TO REDUCE HARM AS MUCH AS
YOU CAN.
IT'S QUITE SIMPLE IT'S WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN DOING FOR DECADES UP
UNTIL THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
ROLLING BACK THE THE RULES AND
THE SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW.
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS IN LINE WITH
TRUMP IS COMPLETELY FALSE AS
STATED IN THE REPORT IN JANUARY
JANUARY TENTH TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
ACTUALLY AFFIRMED THE POSITION
THAT THIS BILL TAKES -- THAT TO
PROHIBITIONS CAN AND DO APPLY TO
DIRECT INCIDENTAL TAKE.
UP THIS OPINION WAS SUSPENDED I
WITHIN A COUPLE WEEKS OF PRESENT
JUMPING ELECTED AND IN DECEMBER
WAS COMPLETELY.
LEVEL OF THE L. ONE EIGHTY
OCCURRED AND WITH THE RULES OF
INCIDENTAL TAKE WHICH ARE NOW
SOON GONNA BE PERMANENTLY
CODIFIED BUT THE BOND
INSPIRATION.
WILL TAKE EFFECT SO -- WHAT
PRESIDENT OF IT?
BUT PRESERVATION MY THE WHAT WAS
IN THE PROCESS OF DOING THAT
REMAIN IN PLACE.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT BE NECESSARY.
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
LONGSTANDING PRACTICE IS NOW
BEING REVERSED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION -- IN SO THAT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE I KNOW A
LOT OF CONFUSION IS BEING PLACED
HERE THIS IS NOT GONNA RESTRICT
THE OPERATION OF ANY THE
INDUSTRIES IN THE FACT.
A BILL THAT THAT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION HELP TO KILL LAST
YEAR -- AB TWENTY TO TWENTY
SEVEN WAS.
WHAT WAS AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF BEST PRACTICES
BY ALL THESE INDUSTRIES WHICH
ALLOW THE INDUSTRIES OF THE COM
PORT WITH BUT THEY -- DIEM AS
BEST PRACTICES AND IT IS ALMOST
A BALL THOSE BEST PRACTICES --
AND AND WE CAN CLARIFY THAT
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW AND NOT
WORRY ABOUT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SAYS AND GIVES A MUCH
MORE.
ABILITY TO WORK WITH US AS A
STATE TO PUT IN PLACE -- RULES
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR OUR
INDUSTRIES I LIKE I SAID FOR FOR
DECK OVER FOUR DECADES AND AND
YOU'LL SEE ALSO -- THAT SINCE.
SEVENTEEN OF FORMER LEADERS THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR
REPRESENTING WHITE HOUSE IS BACK
TO THE NIXON ADMINISTRATION
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE CO SIGNED A
LETTER.
OPPOSING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INTERPRETATION AND URGING
SUPPORT FOR THE MBTA WE THIS
BILL IS IN LINE WITH THOSE
SEVENTEEN FORMER DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR LEADERS.
IN SUPPORTING THE M. B. T. A..
THESE INDUSTRIES ARE NOW ARE
RAISING CONCERNS HAVE BEEN DOING
JUST FINE FOR THE PAST FOUR
DECADES.
THEY'VE BEEN PROTECTING THE
BIRDS TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY THEY'VE BEEN PROSPERING
WE'VE ENCOURAGE THEM TO PROSPER
WHETHER BE SOLAR OR AG OR TIMBER --
BUT THESE RULES ARE IN PLACE TO
SIMPLY SAY THAT WE DO HAVE A
ROLE IN OR RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT MIGRATORY BIRDS AS WE
PROMOTE THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
BOTH CAN BE DONE AS THE STATE
HAS SHOWN. FOR OVER FOUR DECADES
AND THE SUGGESTION THAT SOMEHOW
THIS BILL IS GOING UP ON WINE
THAT IS QUITE THE OPPOSITE IS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THAT'S
UNWINDING OUR ABILITY TO PROTECT.
OUR ENVIRONMENT PROTECT OUR
BIRDS AND WORK WITH OUR INDUSTRY
TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
FROM DIS -- MISSILES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YEAH OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU -- MISTER KALRA FOR
ADDRESSING THAT I KNOW THAT THE
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION OF A WE
COULD FOLLOW UP WITH FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION OR MAYBE.
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU WANT TO
ALLOW THEM TO TALK ABOUT AT
LEAST THIS POINT THAT WAS ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS OF WHETHER THIS WAS
FORMALIZED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OR NOT.
THE MISTER KALRA RESPONDED BUT
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED WAS IT.
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED UNDER
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION DOORS.
AND THEN CHANGING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THERE
SEEMS TO BE.
A DISCREPANCY HERE.
PAGE THREE OF THE OF THE
ANALYSIS YOU'LL SEE -- THE
DESCRIPTION THIS LISTER'S
OPINIONS -- THIS.
BOTTOM TWO PARAGRAPHS THANK I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY I AGREE
WITH WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
SAYING WHAT I WHAT I WHAT I
MEANT AND MAYBE IT WAS UNCLEAR
WHAT I SAID WAS.
THE DECADES OF STANDING LAW THAT
THAT AUDUBON THE SPONSORS AND
THE AUTHOR SAYING HAS BEEN IN
PLACE WAS ONLY FORMALIZED.
AS RECENTLY AS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WHEN IT WAS FORMALIZED
AFTER THAT THE TRUMP DECISION
CAME I WASN'T TRYING TO SUGGEST
THAT THANK YOU FOR THE KIND OF
CRAZY WITH EACH OTHER I
APOLOGIZE BUT MISUNDERSTOOD THE
POINT YOU'RE MAKING OKAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IN AND YOU KNOW THANK
YOU THE SCORE FOR RECOGNIZING
YOU KNOW CAL FREQUENT ENERGY IN
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY AS WELL AS
THEIR OPPOSITION -- IS IT YOUR
ATTENTION THAT THEY ARE TO BE
PROSECUTED UNDER THE ACT I MEAN
IS BECAUSE THAT'S THE
INTERPRETATION THAT THEY HAVE
NOW.
NO THEY'LL BUILD OPERATE THE
SAME OF THE BEEN OPERATE
OPERATING FOR DECADES -- AND AND
THAT JUST MEANS THAT THEY HAVE
TO PUT IN MEASURES TO THE BEST
OF THEIR ABILITY TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INCIDENTAL TAKES --
AND EXAMPLES AB AND AND BUT IN
FACT -- THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
THE BOAT OUR DEPARTMENT WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH THEM ON AS OPPOSED TO
RELYING ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS WILL ACTUALLY
ALLOW FOR MORE INCLUSIVENESS IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS AS EASY AS
THIS IS A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
THEN MAYBE FOR AS LONG NOW MAYBE
THAT'S SOMETHING. TO CLARIFY
YEAH YEAH THAT IS THIS THE AGAIN
IF THEY HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED LOS
FORTY YEARS OF THE RIGHT ABOUT
IT NOW.
OKAY AND THEN -- I DO WANNA GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK --
TO LISA FORCE LANDOWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA THE LACES FORSTER'S
ASSOCIATION WHERE THEY SEE THIS
IS PROBABLY AN OPPOSITION TO
GOVERNOR BROWN AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S.
ACTIONS I MEAN WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO THINK THAT UP YOU KNOW THIS
THIS I DON'T THAT ALL IN IT
CONSISTENT WITH THE ACTIONS THAT
I SUPPORT THAT OUR EFFORTS TO
ENSURE.
THAT TO OUR FORESTRY INDUSTRY
WORKS WITH OUR STATE AND TERMS A
WILDFIRE SUPPRESSION AND OF
ENSURING THAT OUR FORCIBLE
MANAGE OTHERS NOTHING IN THIS
THAT COUNTERS THAT IN FACT.
I I BELIEVE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OPINION FROM NOVEMBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
CONSISTENT AS WELL WITH THE
GOVERNOR BROWN AS WELL AS
GOVERNOR OF A NUISANCE POSITION.
OKAY AND THEN YOU HAD MENTIONED
YOUR PREVIOUS LEGISLATION AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN SO
WHAT'S THE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
LAST YEAR'S BILL IN THIS YEAR'S
BILL LESTER THEIR WORKING WITH
US TO TRY TO MAKE IT ACTUALLY
AMENABLE FOR INDUSTRY AND AND I
THINK THAT WE HAD GREAT PROGRESS
MADE -- THIS YEAR ALL OF A
SUDDEN -- THE CLAIM IS THAT THIS --
BILL'S GOING TO SOMEHOW.
MAKE IT.
CHALLENGES FOR THEIR INDUSTRIES
TO OPERATE AND IS JUST NOT TRUE
GOT IT SO IT'S A REITERATION OF
LAST YEAR'S BUT AGAIN THIS YEAR.
YOU JUST TRY TO PUSH IT THROUGH
THE PROCESS YEAH IT'S IS I THINK
THAT.
COMING INTO THIS YEAR UP AGAIN
LOOK WE ARE WE STILL HAVE THE
SAME OPEN DOOR -- TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE LOOK AT THE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CONTINUED AND FOR
SOME OF THE BAG OF BUBBLE WRAP
MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT THAT
HAS BEEN IN PLACE -- AND HAS
BEEN WORKING JUST FINE FOR FOUR
DECADES THAT WE JUST CONTINUE TO
DO WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR
DECADES WORKING WITH INDUSTRY TO
ENSURE.
THAT INDUSTRY -- ALSO HAS THE
ABILITY TO IMPOSE IMPLEMENT
THEIR BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES.
I HAD TO PROTECT MIGRATORY BIRDS
AND I THINK BUT WHAT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE -- LAST YEAR IS
THAT OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL'S COME
FORWARD AND SUPPORTED OUR
POSITION.
OKAY THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
AND I STILL HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BUT YOU KNOW I'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU THANK YOU BUT
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN SOLAR THE
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION AND THEN
I'M YOU KNOW I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING WITH WILD FIRES.
AND WHETHER THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOME
WILL GOVERNOR BROWN HAVE DONE --
SO WE'LL BE ABLE TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY BUT LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THE AMENDMENTS AND LOOK FOR TO
HOPEFULLY MAYBE IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU IN A QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
THESE.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN -- AND THANK
YOU THIS CALL FOR A DISCUSSION
AS WELL COMMITTEES ARE FOR
TRAXXAS OUT SOME OF THESE ISSUES --
I THINK WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT
THERE CERTAINLY IS A DISCREPANCY
BETWEEN.
THE INTENT OF YOUR BILL -- HAS
YOU SEE IT MEANT -- TO TO
OPERATE AND I THINK THE CONCERNS
ARE MOST -- CAPTURE MY ATTENTION
THE SOLAR AND WIND INDUSTRY --
MANY OF US HAVE BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF EXTREME INCREASING
THE RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
IF THIS IN PERIL THAT -- THAT
WOULD BE CONCERNING TO OTHER
BILLS ARE THE VOTES WE TAKE AND
YOU DON'T SEE THESE IS BEING --
IN CONFLICT NOT AT ALL IN FACT
MAY I REPRESENT A DISTRICT WITH
CAPITAL SILICON VALLEY SON POWER
IN A NUMBER OF OTHER SOLAR OF A
MAJOR OF SOLAR MANUFACTURERS ARE
BASED IN MY DISTRICT -- AND SO I
I THERE'S NOTHING THAT I WOULD
DO CERTAINLY TO HINDER -- WHAT I
AGREE -- OR IMPORTANT GOALS IN
TERMS RENEWABLE ENERGY AND AGAIN --
THESE INDUSTRIES HAVE BEEN
GROWING DRAMATICALLY IN OUR
STATE THANKS TO THE WORK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING WITH THIS.
RULE IN PLACE AND AND THAT'S NOT
LOST ON ME -- AT THE SAME TIME
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS A DISCREPANCY
TO GET YOU CAN OFFER TODAY OR
MAYBE A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT.
TO ALLAY THOSE CONCERNS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP THE STAY
ON TRACK TO MEET ITS OF HER
PERCENT RENEWABLE GOAL.
YEAH WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
IS TO ALLOW THE INDUSTRIES TO
WORK WITH OUR DEPARTMENT TO COME
UP WITH BEST MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES -- WORKING TOGETHER SO
NOT THE STATE SAYS THIS IS WHAT
YOU GOT THEM EVENT BUT THE
INDUSTRY SAYING THESE ARE THE
BEST THESE ARE THE THIS IS WHAT
WE DO TO PROTECT.
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO BE IN AGREEMENT
WITH IT AND SUPPOSE HAVE K. WELL
LET'S JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DOING THE BEST WE CAN -- PULL IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE BEST MANAGER
PRACTICE THAT WE ALL CAN AGREE
ON INTO YOU KNOW IT'S TO YOUR
THIS NOT THE ONLY BILL I'M AWARE
OF THAT'S ATTEMPTING TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST ANY.
OF FEDERAL ROLLBACKS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKER PROTECTIONS
OF THE PRO TEM HAS SENATE BILL
ONE HOW DOES THIS BILL INTERACT
WITH WITH THAT.
THANK YOU I I THINK IT'S IT'S
CONSISTENT -- BUT THOSE OTHER
BILLS -- AND I THINK THIS BILL
IS ACTUALLY UNIQUE.
IN THAT IT'S NOT JUST PUSHING
BACK IS BASICALLY SAYING
CALIFORNIA WANTS OPERATE WE'VE
ALWAYS BEEN OPERATING WHICH HAS
BEEN IN THE COURSE OF FEDERAL
LAW.
SO IT'S REALLY.
UP TO THE THE GOP
ADMINISTRATIONS PULLING BACK AND
WE'RE JUST SAYING HEY LET'S JUST
KEEP DOING WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR DECADES.
WELL IN IN THE THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF SENATOR ATKINS
INTENT -- WITH HER LEGISLATION
OF NINETEEN THE STATUS QUO LIKE
NO BY NOT ROLLING BACK MEANS
WE'RE CONTINUING.
THE WAY WE'VE ALWAYS OPERATED
THE TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE
BILLS COULD BE COMPLEMENTARY OR
PERHAPS -- Và STATED THAT THE
OTHER DAY ABOUT A SPECIFIC BILL
ONE THERE I DIDN'T HEAR THE SAME
CONCERN SO I MONEY IF THERE'S
APPROACH IN THAT BILL THAT --
COULD BE PUT INTO THIS ONE ARE
SOMEHOW HARMONIZED OR WHATEVER --
BUT WHEN HEARING FROM YOU IS A
IS A CLEAR INTENT TO NOT.
DISRUPT OF OUR HARM IT WAS MADE
CLEAR TO ME THAT -- THERE ARE
NUMBER CHALLENGES IN THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY CURRENTLY.
WHETHER IT'S WILD FIRES -- IT
MAKES UTILITY BANKRUPTCY SO ON
SO FORTH SO IT'S A FRAGILE
ENVIRONMENT I UNDERSTAND WHY
PEOPLE WOULD BE ON ON WHAT'S
FAVORITE YOU UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY'RE CONCERNED -- SO I'D ASK
YOU CONTINUE DO THAT WORK -- I
DON'T REPRESENT THAT I
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF AG AND
SOME THE OTHER FOLKS AS WELL AS
I DO -- SOLAR SHE WHICH IS
THERE'S ABUNDANCE OF AND IN SAN
DIEGO -- IN SO -- WITH WITH YOUR
IN CURRENT WITH YOUR COMMITMENT --
I I APPRECIATE THAT ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT. TO VOTE -- FOR
ANYTHING THE FEDERAL
MINISTRATION IS PURSUING IN THE
IN THE CONTEXT OF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL.
PROTECTION.
GIVEN THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT IS THERE I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOUR INTENT IS.
CHOOSE BETWEEN TRUMP IN CAR I
THINK I KNOW WHAT I'M GONNA BE
GOING -- IN SO I JUST ASK YOU
CAN TO WORK WITH THOSE
INDUSTRIES A TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING TO HARM A
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO WITH RELATIVE --
TO TO CLIMATE CHANGE PROTECTING
THE BIRD IS REALLY IS IS NICE
BUT THE PLAN IS ALSO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU MISTER JERRY I AGREE A
100% OF NOT ONLY DO I NOT INTEND
TO DO ANYTHING THAT'S GOING TO
BE DESTRUCTIVE OF SOLAR AND WIND
BUT A DESTRUCTIVE A BAG OF
FORESTRY IN OTHER INDUSTRIES AS
WELL THAT OUR CREDIT CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. TO CALIFORNIA.
IN A QUESTIONS PLEASE DOCTOR.
YEAH I HAVE A SOME --
TECHNICOLOR FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
I I KNOW YOUR SPIRIT -- IN
PROTECTION OF MIGRATORY OUT
BIRDS -- HOWEVER -- THIS IS SAW --
IN.
CONTRADICTION TO OFF.
OF FEDERAL POLICY.
HOW MANY TIMES SO WHAT WHAT?
NOT HOW MANY TIMES SO IT WOULD
BE A STATE.
THE REGULATIONS EVERY TIME WHEN
WE DON'T AGREE WITH THE FEDERAL --
POLICY THAN WE HAVE TO SET OUR
OWN POLICY WHICH I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE THE ISSUE US.
CONSTITUTION DEFINES SO WHETHER --
OUR STATE HAS A A WAR RIGHT --
TO PROCEED.
WITH OUR OWN.
REGULATIONS IN DEFIANCE OF THE
FEDERAL POLICY.
IT'S NOT DEFIANCE -- OUR STATE
HAS THE RIGHT. TO HAVE MORE
STRINGENT RULES AS IS CURRENTLY
BACK WITHOUT THIS BILL CURRENT
LAW ALREADY ALLOWS THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION. TO CONFORM WITH
OR TO FURTHER RESTRICT THE RULES
AND REGULATIONS PRESCRIBED
PRESCRIBED UNDER MBTA.
SO.
YOU KNOW I THINK STATES DO HAVE
A RIGHT.
AB TO BE ABLE TO BUT HAVE SELF
DETERMINATION ESPECIALLY AS IT
APPLIES TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS PROTECTING OUR FOR
PRESS THE TECHNO COMMUNITY.
NOW.
AS HER LUCK AMARE ONE I INDUSTRY
ALSO WE ARE TOTALLY DIFFERENT
CALIFORNIA LAW AND THE FEDERAL
AND WE AT THAT HAS CREATED A LOT
ABOUT YOU KNOW PROBLEMS TO SOLVE
THIS MAY BE AN UP AND ON THE
HILL.
CONFLICTING ISSUE AND THE HOW --
WE MAY RUN INTO LAW.
YEAH [inaudible]
MANY OTHER.
ON INTENDED CONSEQUENCES UP BY
CREATING OUR IN ALL THE
REGULATIONS WELL THE DIFFERENCE
IS THAT UNDER FEDERAL LAW --
CANNABIS HAS NEVER BEEN LEGAL UP
THE MBTA WAS FEDERAL LAW FOR A
HUNDRED YEARS UP UNTIL TWO YEARS
AGO -- AND SO I THERE'S A BIG
DISTINCTION THERE WERE BASICALLY
UP STRENGTHENING A RULE THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST EVEN NOW STILL
THE MBTA STILL IN FORCE OF THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS THIS
BEEN NARROWED DRAMATICALLY.
SO THIS IS JUST A A A
STRENGTHENING OF CURRENT FEDERAL
LAW.
IF I COULD ADD TO SERVE.
AMONG THE TO THERE.
THE OTHER PROVISIONS OF CODE
INCLUDING FISHING GAME CODE
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED WHICH MAKES
IT ILLEGAL TO TAKE.
NATIVE BIRDS AT THIRTY FIVE OH
THREE WHICH LEADS TO PER BIRDS
NESTS AND EGGS THIRTY FIVE OH
THREE WHICH SPECIFICALLY A
RAPTOR.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF PARTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CODE THAT PROVIDE
THESE FLAT PROHIBITIONS ON THE
TAKE OF MIGRATORY BIRDS AND HAVE
FOR DECADES.
AND SO THE CLICK WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO SOLVE HERE IS THAT NOW
THERE'S A CHANGE IN THE FEDERAL
INTERPRETATION OF MBTA THAT IS
INTRODUCED THIS INCONGRUITY
POTENTIALLY.
WITHIN THE FIT WITHIN THE STATE
FISH AND GAME CODE.
BUT THOSE DOES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
THERE AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN.
THE THE RIGHT OF THE STATE -- TO
MANAGE ATTENTION WILDLIFE IS
EMBEDDED IN OUR CONSTITUTION AND
RECOGNIZED BY THE US SUPREME
COURT IS REALLY PROVINCE OF EACH
STATE.
AS PART OF ITS SOVEREIGN RIGHT
SO WE ARE VERY COMFORTABLE IN
THAT RESPECT -- THE WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DECIDE HOW TO
REGULATE OUR FISH AND WILDLIFE
IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU HE THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA NIGHT.
MISS MOST THE PRESENTATION BUT
I'VE I'VE KIND OF BEEN LOOKING
AT THIS ISSUE.
YOU KNOW I I THINK THIS
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
JUST ON THE PERSON MY
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK THE
PERSPECTIVE A LOT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ESPECIALLY LIKE IN
THE AGRICULTURAL.
FIELD LIKE -- UP.
OF ALL MAKE A AN ANALOGY TO
CLEAN WATER ACT -- SO.
THERE WAS GONNA BE A A VERY
LARGE EXPANSION OF CLEAN WATER
ACT UNDER FEDERAL LAW EPA WAS
FORMALLY IN ITS RULES -- AND WE
HAD HAD A CONSISTENT.
VERY CLEAR DEFINITION OF CLEAN
WATER ACT ESPECIALLY IN YOU KNOW
WELL.
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT ASPECTS
BUT WE KNEW LIKE HEY THIS IS
THIS IS A WETLAND THIS IS.
WHAT'S CONSIDERED.
YOU KNOW -- NEIL -- FILL IN A
WET LANDER OR HAVE IN A
DISCHARGE -- AND WITH THOSE NEW
RULES WERE BEING PROMULGATED IT
WAS GONNA DRASTICALLY IMPACT
LIKE JUST THE ABILITY TO LIKE
SAY PLAN A FIELD.
READ TO GO PLAN A NEW ORCHARD
WAR -- TO OR EVEN TO DO ROUTINE
PRACTICES SUCH AS CULTIVATION --
AND OTHER THINGS AND AND IT'S
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE EVEN A RICE
FIELD.
YOU KNOW LIKE LIKE LIFE FORM
WOULD HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED A
WETLAND EVEN THOUGH IT'S ONLY A
WETLAND BECAUSE WE'VE MADE IT
SUCH RIGHT WE FLOOD THE FIELD.
ON PURPOSE -- AND SO YOUNG THESE
DRASTIC EXPANSIONS THERE'S WORD
DOES WERE ULTIMATELY STOPPED
RIGHT THAT RULED THAT RULE
MAKING THE STOPPED.
AND THEN NOW.
THE STATE WATER BOARD IS
CONSIDERING THEIR OWN RULES --
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT ARE
GOING TO BASICALLY TAKE IT TO
THAT LEVEL AND SO.
IN THE SAME WAY I FEEL LIKE. FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE WE FEEL
LIKE THERE'S A LOT OF
REGULATIONS ARE PRETTY STRINGENT --
AND THE MINUTE WE GET A LITTLE
BIT A REGULATORY RELIEF IT'S
KIND OF LIKE THE STATE COMES
GOES WELL NO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GIVE YOU THAT REGULATORY RELIEF
WE'RE GONNA.
EVEN TAKE IT UP A NOTCH OR IN
THIS CASE TAKE IT BACK -- TO
WHERE IT WAS AND I MEAN IN YOUR
SPECIFIC CASE I THINK IT'S
REALLY MORE ABOUT UNINTENTIONAL
TAKE.
RIGHT AN INCIDENTAL TAKE.
AND CERTAINLY NOBODY'S OUT THERE
GOING MAN WE WANT.
TO YOU KNOW JUST ANNIHILATE BIRD
POPULATIONS.
YOU KNOW AS AS AS A HUNTER AS A
AS A MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION WHICH IS A
SUPPORTER OF YOUR BILL -- WE
WANT TO BE GOOD STEWARDS OF OF
OUR WATER FALLON OUR IN OUR BIRD
POPULATIONS IN THE STATE'S BIG
PART OF THE ECONOMY IT'S AND
JUST BY VIRTUE OF THE SPECIES
ITSELF IS CRITICAL RIGHT -- BUT
ALSO IN IN CONDUCTING.
ROUTINE BUSINESS ACTIVITIES NOW
WITH THE BURGEONING SOLAR
INDUSTRY AND WIND INDUSTRY RIGHT.
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
INCIDENTAL TAKES THAT ARE NOT
INTENTIONAL OR NOT TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW -- YOU'RE NOT
INTENSELY GOING OUT AND TRYING
TO YOU KNOW HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THAT BIRD POPULATION.
BUT THIS IS GOING TO AND SO NOW
WE'RE FINALLY GOING TO GET A
LITTLE BIT OF REALLY FUN THAT
ONLY TO HAVE A GO.
RIGHT BACK.
TO A MORE STRINGENT ENFORCEMENT
OF THAT RIGHT SO.
ARE YOU SEE YOU SEE WHERE I'M
COMING FROM THERE I MEAN THERE'S
CAN WE GET A BREAK.
WELL CAN I GUESS WHERE I'M GUY I
MEAN LOOK AT THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH.
COMPLAINTS THERE'S BEEN OVER THE
LAST FORTY YEARS FROM INDUSTRY
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THIS WAS
BEEN IN PLACE.
THE ROLE BY NECESSITY HAS TO BE
REGARDING INSTEAD I'LL TAKE
BECAUSE INTENTIONALLY TAKES
ALREADY ILLEGAL.
UNLESS YOU HAVE A PERMIT.
SO I MEAN OBVIOUSLY INCIDENTAL
TAKE IS HOW YOU PROTECT
MIGRATORY BIRDS AND HAS BEEN.
A TREATY FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
IT'S BEEN FEDERAL PRACTICE FOR
FORTY YEARS HAS BEEN THE STATE'S
PRACTICE FOR DECADES.
AND SO THIS IS JUST SAYING
EVERYTHING'S WORKING JUST FINE.
WHY YOU KNOW BLOW A AND THIS IS
NOT JUST A SLIGHT MODIFICATION
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY GETTING RID
OF ANY RULE REGARDING AS THAT'LL
TAKE?
WHICH DOESN'T MAKE SENSE BECAUSE
AGAIN OUR INDUSTRIES HAVE BEEN
THRIVING WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT OTHERS HAVE BEST PRACTICES
LET'S TRY TO MITIGATE IT NO
ONE'S BEEN PROSECUTED OPENS
BERMAN.
YOU WILL FIND I MEAN IT'S REALLY
ABOUT JUST MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE DOING THE BEST WE CAN AND
WORKING WITH OUR DEPARTMENT
MAKES WOULD BE THE BEST WE CAN --
IT AND THAT'S WHAT HAS BEEN THE
PRACTICE AND SO I DIDN'T HEAR AN
OUTCRY BEFORE.
IN A DECEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN OR BEFORE FEBRUARY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OF THE TRUMP
MINISTRATION TWO WEEKS INTO THE
MINISTRATION ALL OF A SUDDEN.
COUNTERING THE PRACTICE OF
ADMINISTRATIONS BACK TO THE
NIXON ADMINISTRATION DECIDED TO
STOP ENFORCING -- AND THEN
CHANGED WITH THE THE
INTERPRETATION ALTOGETHER --
THERE WASN'T A BIG OUTCRY FROM
INDUSTRY WHETHER BE ABITIBI
SOLAR OF A YOU BE TIMBER.
THE LAST FORTY YEARS.
IN SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
WE KNOW HOW TO DO IT OUR
INDUSTRY KNOWS HOW TO DO IT.
AND OF COURSE OUR INDUSTRY TO
THE BEST THEY CAN UPDATE THE WE
HAVE SOME OF THE BEST.
OF MITIGATION PRACTICES IN THE
WORLD IN CALIFORNIA WE JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THE CONTINUE.
AND NOT ROLL THEM BACK A IT DOES
IT DOES PRACTICES WERE IN PLACE
AND THEY'RE IN PLACE BECAUSE THE
MBTA NOT BECAUSE THE MBTA'S IN A
COME AFTER WHAT THE HAMMER.
BUT THE MBTA'S HAS US WORK
TOGETHER MAKE SURE WE'RE DOING
THE BEST WE CAN TO PROTECT.
OF THESE MIGRATORY BIRDS IT'S A
SIMPLE AS THAT A IN AND I GET
THAT WHEN THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
GET OUT FROM REGULATION INDUSTRY
WILL OFTENTIMES TAKE IT I AM.
THAT'S FINE THAT'S THEIR
PREROGATIVE PRESENT ARE PROBABLY
TO TO TO SAY THAT'S OKAY -- IT
OKAY THINGS ARE WORKING FINE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
INDUSTRY THE DEPARTMENT'S ALWAYS
WORKED WELL WITH INDUSTRY IN
THIS CASE AS OPPOSED TO WHAT'S
BEEN THE CASE FOR DECADES.
OUR STATE DEPARTMENT CAN'T
DISABLE WE'RE JUST GONNA FALL
THE GUIDANCE OF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THEY DECIDED
TO COMPLETELY BUT CUT OUT ANY
CONSIDERATION FOR INCIDENTAL
TAKE WHICH IS.
COMPLETELY COUNTER TO THE
PRACTICES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR A HUNDRED YEARS
UNDER THE TREATY AT LEAST FOR
DECADES UNDER FEDERAL LAW AND
UNDER CALIFORNIA PRACTICE.
I THINK THAT I THINK YOUR
ARGUMENT THERE MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE YOU KNOW AND AND AND IN
TERMS OF HEY THIS IS HOW THINGS
HAVE BEEN RIGHT -- WHAT I WOULD
JUST?
SAVE YOU AN AND I HOPE MAYBE
SOME WE COULD WORK ON IS LIKE
LET'S TRY AND KEEP THAT STATUS
YOU KNOW AT LEAST KEEP THAT.
THAT STATUS QUO.
BECAUSE THAT'S A BIG PART OF
THIS IS JUST THE UNCERTAINTY
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE UNDER.
I THINK YOU MAY GET ARGUMENT HEY
THERE'S NO UNCERTAINTY HERE
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN THAT WAY RIGHT
NOW.
BUT LIKE FOR INSTANCE IN THESE
WETLAND RULES THAT WERE ABOUT TO
PROMULGATE WILL NOT THAT WE ARE
BUT THAT THE REGULATORY BODIES
WITHOUT OUR WITHOUT ANY OF OUR
AND PUT IT REALLY.
ARE ABOUT TO PROMULGATE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD -- YOU KNOW WE NEED THE
BODY BEEN OPERATING AGAIN JUST
AS YOU ARGUED WE'VE BEEN OPERATE
UNDER THE CLEAN WATER ACT IT'S
HEY THESE ARE THE RULES AND THEN
ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY'RE GONNA
LIKE.
DRASTICALLY EXPAND RIGHT SO I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY.
A LOT OF MERIT TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS LIKE HEY KEEP THINGS
WHERE THEY'RE AT SO THE PEOPLE
HAVE THAT EXPECTATION AND NO.
WHAT'S COMING FORWARD.
IS THAT I I AGREE 1100% ON I
THINK THESE ARE NEW RULES AND
WITH A 100% AS OPPOSED TO THE
WEATHER WAS THE HOUSE CONCERNED
ABOUT THESE ARE NEW RULES AND I
AGREE I I I DON'T.
THIS SHOULDN'T BE USED AS A NEW
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO OUT TO
THESE INTERVIEW THAT'S NOT WITH
THE INTENTION IS REALLY IS AS
HEY LET'S JUST KEEP DOING WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING.
THAT'S CODIFIED IN STATE LAW
WHICH WE DIDN'T NEED TO DO UP
UNTIL COVERED YEARS WE DIDN'T
NEED TO CODIFY THE STATE LAW NOW
WE NEED TO CODIFY IT JUST TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE THE WAY
WE'VE BEEN OPERATING AND SO
THAT'S FULLY MY INTENTION.
AGAIN -- TO WORK WITH ALL THESE
INDUSTRIES TO MAKE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO WORK
WITH THESE INDUSTRIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN OPERATE IN A
WAY THAT SUCCESSFUL AND WORKS
FOR THEM.
BUT AT LEAST HAS SOME BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES IN TERMS OF
PRODUCING ABOUT A CELTIC KNOT
ELIMINATING IT OTHER GOING TO
BRING UP A LOT OF BIRDS ARE
GOING TO DIE.
THAT'S PART OF WHAT THESE
INDUSTRIES THEY CAN'T HELP IT
IT'S NOT THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO IT.
THEY'RE NOT TRYING TO KILL A
SINGLE BIRD -- BUT BIRDS ARE
GOING TO DIE WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MINIMIZE THAT AS BEST WE CAN
WHILE ON THESE INDUSTRIES
OPERATE.
OF PRACTICALLY.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YOU DO HAVE A MOTION SECOND IT
DOES HAVE A TO PASS. TO SOME
APPROPRIATIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST SHARE THAT THEM MY HOPE IS
THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH -- THE OPPOSITION -- IF I
RECALL CORRECTLY -- THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN LESS OPPOSITION LAST.
GO AROUND WITH THE PREVIOUS BILL
IN IT.
HAD A CHALLENGE GETTING OUT OF
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND SOME
HOPEFUL THAT THERE WILL BE.
SOME DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND HAVE EXPRESSED
A CONCERN IN SOME INSTANCES IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME.
WORD SMITHING THAT WOULD CLARIFY.
CERTAIN TENSE ODD TO GIVE SOME
FOLKS THAT CERTAINTY THAT.
NOTHING REALLY HERE'S CHANGING
BEYOND WHAT THE PRACTICES THEN
FOR FOUR DECADES ALREADY HAS
BEEN REITERATED HERE.
AND IN OTHER INSTANCES OR MAY
NOT BE ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN DO --
TO CHANGE -- THE POSITION BUT
NEVERTHELESS I'M HOPEFUL THAT
YOU'LL.
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THEM ARE
OURS OUR TEAM HERE IS PREPARED
TO HELP FACILITATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS IN.
HOPES THAT THE BILL MOVES OUT
APPROPRIATIONS IN THAT IT'S ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND GETS TO
SUPPORT.
THE NEED TO MOVE THIS FORWARD SO
THAT'S MY CLOSING.
I THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THE
BILL THERE'S A MOTION A SECOND.
US FOR ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO.
CHOI NO CHOI NO TWO ARE CHIU AYE
GALLEY.
KELLY NO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
KALRA I'VE.
KALRA I LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
**** A RUBIO NOT VOTING SALAS.
SALAS NOT VOTING WOULD
[inaudible]
WOOD I SIX TO THREE TWO MONTHS.
OKAY NEEDS TO MORE BELIEVE IT ON
CALL [inaudible]
CALLS.
BY THIS TIME WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND LET THE CALLS ON SEVERAL
ITEMS -- MY JUST START FROM THE
TOP OKAY -- MAN CLEAR COULD GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL ON THE
ITEMS THAT STILL NEED VOTES.
ADAM NUMBER ONE AB TWO EIGHTY
FOUR GALLAGHER.
HI GALLAGHER AYE [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DALY I FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
I GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA.
LEVINE BY LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD WRITE WOOD I
TWELVE HOUSES.
THE BILL IS OUT ON A TWELVE
THOUGH.
THE NEXT ITEM [inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER AYE GALLAGHER AYE.
DELI.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
I GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE LOCKER RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD.
YOU WOULD CALL RIGHT KALRA.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
KALRA I THIRTEEN TWO ZERO TO
TELL THIRTEEN OH CONSENT
COUNTERPARTS IS.
AB FOR FORTY ONE ITEM NUMBER
THREE GALLAGHER.
AYE GALLAGHER AYE [inaudible]
DALY.
KELLY NOT VOTING.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA [inaudible]
CHOLERA.
CALLER I'D LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS NOT VOTING WOULD.
WOULD I TEND TO WANT TO PASS.
THE BILLS OUT TEN THE ONE MAYBE
FOR FORTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER FOUR
CHIU.
CHIU I'D DAILY.
DALY AYE.
GLORIA [inaudible]
THAT IS [inaudible] THIRTEEN IS
THAT BILL YES. FOR HEATING.
THE BILL IS OUT ON A THIRTEEN OF
A THE BEEF AB FOUR FIFTY FOUR
ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
FIVE CRISTINA GARCIA
[inaudible]
GLORIA.
AND THAT THIS. ONE SIX WE NEED
TO MONTROSE BUT SAYS STILL ON
CALL.
AB FOR EIGHTY NINE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER I'D WRITTEN TO ZERO
TO PASS.
POSTED ON YEAH.
OKAY THE BILL IS OUT ON A
FOURTEEN TO ZERO VOTE.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN DALY NOT REALLY.
DELHI NOT VOTING GALLAGHER BY
GALLAGHER I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD I WOULD I NINE TEN
ELEVEN TO PASS.
OKAY THE BILLS ON ELEVEN ZERO
VOTE.
SB SIX THIRTY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
NINE GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER I
CHU.
CHU AYE ALLEY.
KELLY I FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA I SALAS.
SALAS I WOULD I WOULD I FOURTEEN
TWO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
FOURTEEN ZERO DO PASS.
SB SIX FIVE EIGHT ITEM NUMBER.
TEN GALLAGHER.
NUMBER GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
DALY.
CITY.
DELHI NOT VOTING [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA I TWO ZERO TO PASS THE
BILL IS OUT ON EIGHT NINETY NINE
AND A NINE TO ZERO VOTE.
AB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE GALLAGHER HI GALLAGHER I
DALY [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA HI. TWO ZERO TO PASS.
THAT BILLS OUT ON A TWELVE ZERO
THE IT -- WE DO NOT HAVE ONE ON
CALL THIS FRIEDMAN FIFTEEN
ALREADY DONE [inaudible]
YEAH YES.
OKAY WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON CALL.
I BELIEVE IT'S ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE REGISTER FOR IS ON HIS WAY.
TO NEEDS TO GO.
ON TO WHICH IS OKAY [inaudible]
LOW.
STRING GIVE ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES
OR SO [inaudible]
UHHUH [inaudible]
UHHUH.
I THINK IN GENERAL LIKE.
I HAVE READ THAT [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH -- BUT IT WAS LIKE NOTHING
WAS WORKING WITH ABOUT
[inaudible]
ORDER [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS.
IS ALSO A SENATOR [inaudible]
THE SERVICE [inaudible]
WE SO [inaudible]
THE SONG [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
SOMEONE.
I'M HAPPY WITH THAT.
WHAT THE HELL?
IN THIS AND THAT BUT UHHUH
.
COMMON PROBLEMS BASICS AND
CONDITIONALLY OVER.
WHATEVER.
OUR MISTER GLORIA.
GOOD TO SEE YOU MY FRIEND YOU
HAVE THE SAME PROBLEM THAT I DO
WHICH IS I I HAVE THREE KIDS
THREE COMMITTEE IS AT THE SAME
TIME [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE'LL GO CALL THE ROLL --
FOR MISTER GLORIA THE MADAM
CLERK.
AB FOUR FIVE FOUR ITEM NUMBER
FIVE KALRA -- THE MISSING VOTES
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
GLORIA HI GLORIA I LET'S JUST
RUN THROUGH AS OTHER BOATS
[inaudible]
TO YEAH [inaudible]
GARCIA I EIGHT TO THREE I I I
DON'T KNOW.
YES OKAY SO THAT BILLS OUT ON A
TWO THREE VOTE.
STARTING AT THE TOP.
I DON'T KNOW THAT. EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER ONE
GLORIA HI.
GLORIA I KALRA.
KALRA HI. FOURTEEN TWO ZERO TO
THAT BILLS ALREADY OUT RIGHT BUT
ON A FORTINO NOW.
AB.
FOR FORTY ONE GLORIA HI GLORIA I
IT'S ONE TO ONE OKAY THAT'S
ELEVEN DESERVE US ALREADY OUT
BUT YES [inaudible]
AB. FOR FOR FORTY EIGHT GLORIA
HI GLORIA I WORKED.
A TON OF FORTINO.
AB FIVE FIVE SIX GLORIA.
I GLORIA AYE. TWO ZERO TWELVE A
AB SIX THIRTY EIGHT GLORIA.
I GLORIA I IT'S FOURTEEN TO ZERO
IT'S ALREADY OUT ON NOW FOURTEEN
ZERO OF A SB SIX FIVE EIGHT
GLORIA AYE.
GLORIA AYE. TEN ZERO OKAY THAT
BILLS ALREADY OUT ON ATTENDED
ZERO VOTE.
AB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR ITEM TWELVE
GLORIA I GLORIA I THE BILL IS
ALSO ALREADY OUT ON THE
THIRTEENTH ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CALL THE ROLL.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR GLORIA AYE
GLORIA AYE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
ZERO ALL RIGHT THIS COMMITTEE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
BUT THE I SAID WELL.
WHERE THEY'RE TAKING YEAH THAT
IS I'M SIZE BUT FROM THE